de prendre place puis qu'on a quand même
un petit peu de retard mais
bon la faute nous en incombe sur ce
retard puisqu'on a été
particulièrement bavard mais AB
bonéciant donc je remercie très
sincèrement le président Arnaud Rousseau
président de la Fédération nationale des
syndicats d'exploitation agricole la
FNSEA qui est le syndicat majoritaire au
sein de la profession agricole d'avoir
accepté d'échanger avec nos commissaires
dans une période pour le moins
extrêmement compliquée et alors même que
votre syndicat est avec d'autres en
première ligne pour faire entendre les
multiples revendications de la prof
agricole la crise à laquelle nous
assistons depuis près de de semaines
maintenant peut d'ors et déjà être
qualifiée d'historique il est vrai que
l'agriculteur et on l'entend on le lit
n'est pas du genre à aller manifester
tous les qu matin l'ampleur de la
mobilisation à laquelle nous assistons
témoigne donc bien d'un mal-être qui
vient de très loin que la chambre des
territoires a senti croître au fil de
ses nombreux travaux que ce soit à
travers le déclin de la compétitivité de
la ferme France ou bien par le prisme
encore trop tabou du suicide en
agriculture que nos rapporteurs
Françoise ferra et Henry Cabanel avaient
très justement qualifi de drames
silencieux les mots de notre agriculture
sont très nombreux manque de
reconnaissance voire agribaching voire
même action violente contre les
agriculteurs comme nous l'avons vu
récemment à Sainte Soline
problématique du revenu qui ne concerne
certes pas tous les agriculteurs mais
une part non négligeable la question des
retraites agricoles trop faiblebl alors
même qu'une loi votée à l'unanimité
censé permettre un calcul sur les 25
meilleures années n'est appelé à entrer
en vigueur qu'en
2026 fléo des normes et des
surtranspositions
franco-française qui m notre
compétitivité et place nos agriculteurs
en situation de concurrence déloyale
avec nos partenaires les plus proches
accord de libre échange qui trop souvent
ne rechigne pas à sacrifier
l'agriculture européenne encore
considérée comme secteur non stratégique
enfin ambigué française intenable sur le
Green Deal européen et sa déclinaison
agricole assurance d'une mort lente de
notre modèle agricole et de ce qu'il
reste de notre souveraineté alimentaire
terre face à cette sédimentation et
c'est un mot que vous employez très
souvent monsieur le Président de
problématique il est peu de dire que le
gouvernement a fort à faire le premier
ministre a tenté vendredi dernier de
séduire les agriculteurs promettant de
mettre l'agriculture au-dessus de tout
très franchement nous n'aurions pas pu
mieux dire en tout cas sur le diagnostic
qui a été dressé en revanche nous
aurions certainement pu mieux faire et
la déception et il faut bien le dire à
la hauteur de la force de de ces mots
mots m TS quelques mesures de bon sens
certes sur le GNR ou encore sur les E
mais où est la vision 10 mesures
technico-administratives et puis s'en va
ou du moins essai puisque les
agriculteurs n'ont pas été dupes et que
la mobilisation se poursuit plus que
jamais et pas plus tard qu'hier lors de
sa déclaration de politique générale le
Premier ministre a annoncé vouloir une
exception agricole française
encore une fois on ne peut que saluer
l'ambition tout en restant dubitatif sur
les traductions concrètes qu'emporteront
toutes ces déclarations d'amour à notre
agriculture au sein de notre commission
nous l'avons déjà dit et je rends
hommage au travail de la précédente
présidente Sophie prima puisque bon
nombre de ces travaux que j'ai cité ont
été faits sous sa présidence si le
Gouvernement entend travailler
sérieusement au redressement de la ferme
France une proposition de loi
transpartisan votter ici au Sénat est
toujours sur la table puisqu'elle n'a
pas été inscrite à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale elle ne règle
peut-être pas tous les problèmes mais je
pense qu'il s'agit là d'une base de
travail solide fruit d'une concertation
avec le monde agricole je m'arrête là
bien évidemment pour vous céder la
parole monsieur le Président pour que
vous nous indiquiez comment vous
accueillez les quelques annonces
quelques annonces du gouvernement et
quelle suite vous entendez donner à
votre mobilisation qui chacun le sait
aura bien une fin mais sur laquelle
aujourd'hui vous êtes particulièrement
déterminé je vous laisse la parole je
précise que l'audition est captée et
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et la vidéo sera ensuite
disponible en vidéo à la demande et je
demande bien sûr à nos collègues qui ne
vont pas manquer de vous poser de
nombreuses questions d'être très concis
et d'éviter les questions redondantes
merci monsieur le Président je vous
laisse la parole très
volontiers merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente et bon bonjour à tous merci
de l'accueil qui m'est réservé ici dans
votre commission à votre invitation pour
parler à la fois de l'agriculture
j'avais déjà eu la chance d'être invité
devant vous il y a maintenant quelques
mois avec un diagnostic qui me
semble-t-il n'est pas très loin de de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et puis donc
évidemment l'idée de de vous décrire ce
qui se passe je voudrais peut-être
commencer par parler de la vision parce
que je pense que c'est ça qui est le
plus intéressant la vision elle est
assez simple on est dans dans dans le
pays qui est est reconnu comme étant
celui qui a une des agricultures les
plus durables au
monde ça veut pas dire que par ailleurs
on n' pas des progrès qui doivent
continuer à être réalisés mais enfin
faisons le constat que quand on regarde
ce qui se passe ailleurs dans tous les
autres pays de la planète on est
finalement avec capacité de production
dans des conditions économiques
environnementales et sociales qui sont
reconnu comme étant les plus élevés de
la planète premier élément ensuite on a
clairement un monde dans lequel on est
dans un milieu ouvert donc on a des
échanges on a qui sont par ailleurs
nécessaires mais j'aurais peut-être
l'occasion d'y revenir si certains
d'entre vous ont des questions et des
questionnements forts d'un secteur
agricole qui est aujourd'hui un secteur
d'ajustement je crois qu'il faut être
capable de de le dire avec aujourd'hui
moins de 400000 exploitations agricoles
professionnelles c'est 100000 de moins
qu' a en 2010 et sur ces 400000
exploitations 100000 font moins de 25000
€ de production BR standard dit
autrement ell ne permettent pas aux
agriculteurs qui qui sont inscrits dans
cette catégorie de pouvoir en vivre ce
sont ça peut-être des doubles actif ça
peut-être des gens qui font autre chose
on sait que sociologiquement on aura
près de la moitié de la population
agricole à renouveler en tous les cas la
moitié d'entre elles partira en retraite
dans les 10 à 12 ans et c'est en tous
les cas 166000 exploitants dans les 5 à
7 ans c'est ce sont les chiffres
officiels voilà un peu le le décor le
tout dans un
contexte où évidemment les sujets de
compétitivité de défis climatiqu de
sujets de décarbonation sont autant de
challenge à relever qui pour
l'agriculteur euh évidemment sont des
soucis
quotidiens un agriculteur on a
l'habitude de le dire à la FNSEA c'est
d'abord un entrepreneur quelle que soit
la taille de son exploitation quel que
soit son son territoire quel que soit
son type de production et donc par
définition il a besoin à la fin de
l'année que son entreprise comme toutes
les entreprises que ce soit un
commerçant ou un artisan dégage du
revenu pour permettre de continuer à
rembourser les investissements à pouvoir
préparer les projets à pouvoir manœuvrer
évidemment à vivre et le constat
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a des écarts de
plus de plus en plus
importants en agriculture enfin le cadre
donc la mission reste la même produire
pour nourrir c'est c'est ça je crois qui
est ATT entendu on peut avoir des
contributions annexes celle de produire
de l'énergie renouvelable demain on sait
qu'on aura dans le cadre de la
planification écologique des sujets de
bouclage de biomasse sur lequel
l'agriculture est attendue et pour
lequel aujourd'hui on a un certain
nombre de réponses qui ne sont pas qui
ne sont pas là c'est pas de la mauvaise
volonté c'est que on sait pas boucler la
totalité des chaînes c'est en toutous
les cas ce qu'on travaille avec le
secrétariat général à la planification
écologique et puis au dehors de donc de
de cet apport de volet énergétique donc
je par je pense à la biomasse ce qu'on
peut faire avec le photovoltaïque sur
les toits notamment nos élevages mais
demain l'agrivoltaïsme puisque il y a un
projet qui est sur la table la
méthanisation peut-être d'autres
solutions demain on a on aura en tous
les cas un élément de réponse au mix
énergétique puis enfin ce qu'on appelle
le volet des aminités positives comment
demain on pourra être rémunéré pour
notre contribution à la décarbonation il
existe d'ors et déjà des propositions
elles sont à ce
stade pas très développé mais enfin ça
existe et aujourd'hui un agriculteur qui
est capable de prouver que son sol va
stocker plus de carbone peut en avoir un
produit et on peut imaginer demain que
d'autres paiements pour services
environnementaux soi aussi un complément
de revenu donc produire pour nourrir
évidemment pour le faire j'ai dit qu'il
fallait du revenu et puis il faut aussi
des conditions de production et je
voudrais en dire un mot ça m'amènera à
ce qu le cadre d'abord dans un cadre
européen puisque vous le savez
l'essentiel des politiques publiques
conduites sur le sujet agricole sont des
politiques européennes alors en premier
le déquel la politique agricole commune
mais mais ça n'est pas la seule
politique qui vient euh sur le champ
agricole avec des sujets évidemment de
de de de contexte européen de plus en
plus de de surtransposition et en tous
les cas de subsidiarité qui conduisent
bien souvent à de la surtransposition
pas de manière
systématique un volet national et puis
euh ensuite des conditions d'échange
donc là je ve faire évidemment mention
euh des accords internationaux alors là
aussi je voudrais être clair la France
agricole ne peut pas se passer de
continuer à échanger qui imagine demain
la viitulture concentrée sur le marché
national c'est sa fin programmée et
immédiate qui imagine que sur le champ
des céréales à un moment où on est dans
une bataille géopolitique avec notamment
la Russie et l'Ukraine sur le continent
africain on puisse passer euh de la
production et puis je pourrais vous
parler des produits laitiers transformés
et d'un certain nombre de d'autres
produits par ailleurs comme toujours on
peut avoir des intérêts offensifs et
défensifs et c'est vrai que sur les
intérêts qu'on souhaite protéger on a
notamment la question de l'élevage je
faudrais en dire un mot parce que c'est
évidemment
central notamment dans les sujets de
planification écologique tout le monde
nous dit que la prairie est quelque
chose d'essentiel puisque sur le plan de
la biodiversité sur le plan du carbone
c'est un levier important mais que par
ailleurs on constate tous les jours que
conserver notamment des bovins que ce
soit en en lait ou en viande c'est
compliqué pour les éleveurs et je le dis
il y a quand même un moment où on pourra
pas avoir des prairies d'un côté et rien
à mettre dessus ça n' pas la prairie a
une fonctionnalité c'est de nourrir un
troupeau voilà et donc du coup il y a
tout un tas de de sujets qui qui qui se
pose sur cette question là au moment où
où ça décapitalise beaucoup voilà donc
ces conditions d'échange qui prévoi
qu'on puisse importer notamment de la
viande bovine mais je vous pourrais vous
parler des ovins dans des conditions de
réciprocité qui questionnent le monde
agricole interroge je le dis c'est pour
ça que j'essaie de rester équilibré
devant vous en disant on peut avoir des
intérêts offensifs et il y en a dans
d'autres secteurs mais ce qu'on constate
c'est que souvent dans les accords
commerciaux la question agricole
vis-à-vis des pays avec lequels on on
veut passer des accords la question de
l'agriculture est souvent une monnaie
d'échange l'Europe est plutôt
exportatrice de biens et services de
produits manufacturés et et les produits
qui veulent signer avec nous les pays
qui veulent signer avec nous des accords
ont plutôt de de de des produits
agricoles ou ou tous les cas du secteur
primaire amené donc il faut qu'on on le
regarde et c'est là où on dit que on a
un sujet de de de règles et de normes
alors je lis beaucoup de choses en ce
moment y compris beaucoup d'excès nous
n'avons jamais dit que il fallait pas de
norme la norme elle est même capable
parfois de N nous protéger donc j'évite
les excès mais je dis que malgré tout il
y a un certain nombre de choses qui ne
sont pas comprises et qui se traduisent
par de la surtransposition ou des choses
qui qui n'ont pas je vous prends un
exemple parce que après tout il faut
quand même être un peu concret
aujourd'hui et c'est des remonté parce
qu'en ce moment tout tout remonte là
mais voilà en production
ovine quand vous avez deux moutons qui
sont dans la même stabulation donc il
peuvent se toucher ça pose pas de
problème mais si si vous une fois par
vous tondez votre mouton la laine qui en
ce moment est un marché très déprimé qui
trouve peu de débouché que vous voulez
la garder la broyer et la mettre au sol
pour faire une litière bien c'est
interdit parce que la laine c'est un
déchet aujourd'hui au sens de la
réglementation voilà bon C exemple est
un parmi d'autres mais voilà
l'agriculteur voyez c'est des choses
qu'il a du mal à comprendre pour des
raisons sanitaires essentiellement
concernant la liine bon je pourrais
multiplier les exemples je voulais vous
dire pourquoi à un moment on ça
questionne alors je le dis tout ça est
une question vous avez bien fait madame
la président de préciser de
sédimentation c'està-dire que ce qui se
passe en ce moment est le cumul de
règles de norme qu'au début vous
acceptez de de de voilà ça ça Râ un peu
mais bon et puis un moment quand quand
vous êtes arrivés dans le trop plein et
bien ça déborde et et c'est le moment
dans lequel on est et et je le dis pour
l'ensemble de mes collègues agriculteurs
qui sont en ce moment sur un certain
nombre de de points en France l'attente
est énorme l'attente est énorme et
peut-être même au-delà de ce que on
imagine avec évidemment des sujets très
nationaux donc ça voilà mais beaucoup de
sujets européens et et je le je l'ai dit
depuis quelques jours en responsabilité
sujet européens ce ne sont pas des
sujets qui se règlent en 3 jours euh sur
voilà donc je je j'essaie d'appeler au
calme et à la
raison on aura aussi je veux le dire
devant cette assemblée parce que c'est
votre rôle un certain nombre de sujets
d'ordre législatif à pouvoir faire
évoluer et notamment dans le cadre de la
ploa la fameuse projet de loi et
d'orientation agricole dont on rabat les
oreilles des agriculteurs depuis an de
long mois oui donc vous nous avvez
promis le passage devant euh les
assemblées avant enfin au début 2023
puis après l'été puis à la fin de
l'année puis au début de l'année puis là
le Premier ministre nous a indiqué qu'il
souhaitait prendre quelques semaines
supplémentaires pour pouvoir compléter
le texte ce qui est plutôt une une bonne
nouvelle alors nous on voudrait vous
dire ce qu'on veut y voir bon évidemment
ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui avec les
éléments d'installation et de
transmission qui est important comment
on transmet les entreprises et
aujourd'hui l'entreprise agricole ne se
transmet pas dans les mêmes conditions
qu'une industrie qu'une entreprise
industrielle et commerciale euh donc ça
c'est important comment on fait pour à
la fois attirer des jeunes les aider à
se lancer dans le métier et faire en
sorte que ceux qui quittent le métier
puissent le faire dans des conditions
dans lesquelles ils ont intérêt à le
faire et pas de dire je reste
agriculteur jusqu'à 70 75 ans avec tous
les sujets de pénnibilité donc il faut
pouvoir accompagner ça on aura tout un
volet autour de la compétitivité alors
je je le dis parce que je sais que cette
maison a travaillé il y a quelques mois
dans une proposition de loi
transpartisane à des sujets de
compétitivité alors est-ce que c'est
cela est-ce qu'on en ajoute d'autres
voilà je je je je laisse les
parlementaires faire leur travail mais
dans tous les cas on a ces sujets très
clairement parce que dans le moment dans
lequel on est on a aussi un sujet de
compétitivité faut accepter de le dire
voilà et puis enfin ce qui est essentiel
pour nous c'est d'y voir des sujets
autour de la souveraineté alimentaire au
premier rang desquels la reconnaissance
que l'agriculture est d'intérêt général
majeur voilà donc après je ne suis pas
juriste des gens sont bien plus
compétents que moi pour pour traiter de
ces sujets mais l'esprit en tous les cas
c'est ça et faire en sorte que quand on
prend des décisions on puisse au moins
euh regarder ce qui est l'impact donc
nous on est très demandeur d'études
d'impact je le dis parce que notamment
on pourra peut-être parler du Green Deal
on a eu un certain nombre de de sujet
sur le Green Deal et et et les études
d'impact qui aujourd'hui montrent que
finalement le Green Deal est un échec il
est un échec pour les associations
environnementales hein il est un échec
pour pour la production et quand vous
voyez qu'au terme des 5 ans de ce mandat
à peu près toute l'Europe agricole et
dehors je suis pas persuadé que voilà
alors c'est pas que le Green Deal il y a
aussi des appareil et sujet de
fonctionnement on a eu un
commissaire européen à l'Agriculture qui
de mon point de vue n'était pas à la
hauteur de de la tâche qui était la
sienne qui n'a pas permis de mettre
cette dynamique et d'essayer de trouver
ce qui mon point de vue et son rôle
espèce de ligne de crête qui permet
aussi de de trouver des consensus en
Europe voilà donc ce sujet bah il est
posé sur la table nous serons en
élection au
mois de juin et et et et les Européens
se se définiront je veux dire aussi que
dans le moment dans lequel on est à la
FNSEA on a veillé à rester dans le cadre
professionnel je le dis parce que les
récupérations
politique ne sont pas notre créneau à la
fnsoa on a des gens qui viennent de la
gauche du centre de la droite et et
maintenant un peu plus de l'extrême
droite voilà mais je j'ai pas de
problème avec ça et et fnso ne prend pas
de position politique je je le dis euh
et on a veillé à ce que il y ait pas de
de récupération à aucun moment en tous
les cas moi j'ai été très clair sur ce
sujet mais j'observe que il y avait la
volonté de de faire ça et je dis aussi
que dans les statuts de la fnsoir si on
s'engage dans un mandat politique en
tous les cas national ou régional on
peut pas garder ses responsabilités
voilà donc dans le moment dans lequel on
est
euh on a eu d'abord une première phase
qui a consisté à être invité comme
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux à
rencontré le Premier ministre que nous
avons fait lundi il y a une semaine euh
voilà donc avec un échange qui
consistait à à poser le diagnostic moi
je j'étais très intéressé de savoir si
nous partagions le le diagnostic c'est
important de savoir si avant de démarrer
à travailler ensemble on est déjà au
clair sur ce que sont les éléments de
force et de faiblesse parce que je
voudrais quand même rappeler dans le
moment dans lequel on est que
l'agriculture a des éléments de force et
que s'il y a des menaces il y a aussi
des opportunités ESS de regarder aussi
comment demain on peut continuer à à
avancer donc on a posé le diagnosticque
avec le Premier ministre et puis on en
est resté là bon je reviens pas sur ce
qui s'est passé vendredi le Premier
ministre qui est descendu en Occitanie
qui a fait une belle opération de
communication qui s'est finalement
traduit par une forme
de
suragacement et puis qui nous a conduit
dans dans la la la la situation la
situation dans laquelle on on est euh je
dis auss aussi que beaucoup de gens en
ce moment critiquent la
fnsoa je pense que le gouvernement est
bien content de nous trouver en ce
moment pour savoir avec qui négocier je
dis aussi très clairement parce que il y
a d'abord pas que la FNSA d'autres
syndicats
enfin chacun sera libre de porter ses
revendications j'ai compris que le
premier ministre recevrait les autres
syndicats en tous les cas pour ce qui
nous concerne après avoir fait des
remontées du terrain on a aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de propositions qui ont
été adressées au Premier ministre et sur
lequel on travaille donc on a eu des
séances de travail voilà donc le premier
ministre souhaite
aller le plus vite possible nous ce qui
nous intéresse c'est qu'on puisse
prendre point par point alors évidemment
en étant là aussi rigoureux entre ce qui
est franco français sur lequel il a la
main ce qui est franco-français sur
lequel on a besoin du législateur donc
je sépare bien ce qui relève du décret
de ce qui relève de de la loi et puis
ensuite on a des sujets européens voilà
qui ne se règleront pas en quelques
jours même si le président de la
République lui-même est à Bruxelles
aujourd'hui et et demain et puis enfin
on aura un rendez-vous électoral
européen dans lequel j'imagine que d'ici
cette échéance chacun portera les
visions et et les agriculteurs se se
définiront voilà peut-être ce que je
voulais vous dire en propos introductif
et je réponds bien évidment à vos
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le le
président de ses premiers propos donc
vous imaginez bien que les questions
sont extrêmement nombreuses donc je je
vais encore vous rappeler soyez concis
précis évitez de trop poser le débat
aller directement à la question à
l'essentiel et bien sûr si la question a
déjà été posée abstenez-vous de la poser
ou trouvez trouvezen vite une autre
alors on va prendre les questions de
Franck Menonville de Frédéric Buval et
de Henry Cabanel oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président de tout
d'abord vous dire que sur le le terrain
il faut vraiment souligner à la fois la
force de la mobilisation mais aussi
l'esprit de responsabilité des des
agriculteurs les les manifestations et
les mobilisations se font dans dans le
calme avec une force de de conviction
mais avec une un vrai esprit de de voilà
de de de de citoyenneté de
responsabilité je crois que vous en êtes
d'ailleurs aussi l'artisan moi je
voudrais peut-être vous dire vous vous
avez évoqué donc ce que vous souhaitez
voir être positionné dans la dans la loi
d'orientation agricole on voit bien que
la la difficulté de de cette crise c'est
qu'elle vient de loin vous parliez de de
ces dientation elle touche à des
facettes européennes elle touche à des à
une érosion de la
compétitivité de l'agriculture française
liée à à une super position de de
politique publique qu'on peut vraiment
aller
aussi mettre sur les 20 années passées
lois sur l'eau Grenelle de
l'environnement et autres où on a
demandé finalement à l'agriculture très
souvent de de répondre à des attentes
environnementales et sociétales et on
sait pas en même temps on n pas armé
puisque le président de la République
aime bien ce terme réarmer n'est-ce pas
la compétitivité de
l'agriculture et donc ma question elle
est simple qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
pour voir lever cette cette crise et ces
barrages en en action et en proposition
immédiate pour répondre il faut le dire
davantage à du à du conjoncturel et
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
voir engagé par le gouvernement et par
l'Europe sur des des mesures plus
structurelles pour
restaurer la compétitivité et la place
de notre agriculture merci Franck
Frédéric
bival merci madame la présidente
monsieur le
Président je vous ai écouté
attentivement et je souhaite vous
assurer qu'à martinque certainement plus
qu'ailleurs l'autonomie ou la
souveraineté alimentaire est un vrai
projet de société pour favoriser la
production locale et permettre à la
population de se nourrir convenablement
en quantité et en qualité en 2020 il y
avait 2680 exploitations agricole à la
Martinique soit une baisse de 19 % par
rapport à 2010 les exploitants agricoles
ne demandent qu'à être plus accompagné
pour produire plus et aussi répondre à
une demande local envahi par des
produits d'importation de dégagements
qui sont devenus de et qui sont souvent
de mauvaise
qualité aussi tris trois pistes de
réflexion sur les problématiques de
l'ricultureemè que je souhaite soumettre
à votre réflection monsieur le Président
la première concerne les spécificités du
foncier de l'accès à la terre entre les
conflits d'usages les contraintes
environnementales climatiques ou
juridiques du fait de la division nos
exploitations sont plus petites plus
enclavées et donc souffre d'un
sous-financement chronique pénalisant la
rentabilité économique du secteur et
donc à terme la la création et la
transmission des exploitations la
seconde piste de réflexion se porte sur
les leviers de production et de
commercialisation adapté aux autres mèes
pour cela je prends un exemple simple
comment aider les mèes de Martinique qui
sont de bonne volonté mais qui ne
parviennent pas en dépis de la loi et
Galim à proposer dans leur cantine des
goyaves ou autres fruits locales plutôt
que des pommes même si les pommes sont
très bonnes tout que les pommes en effet
les productions locales parâtissent des
coups d'entrant de production bien plus
élevé que de l'Hexagone oh là là
oui
oui des des coups d'entr de production
bien plus élevés que de l'exagone en
raison deéloinement géographique ces
cous affectent l'ensemble de la filière
et limite les débouchés commerciaux
alors dans le prolongement desction sur
le TR de ma c'est tout un plan
d'accompagnement que que nous proposons
pour les fili C et local la trè piste
porte sur l'adaptation des financements
des chambres
C ces entités sont souvent les rares
interlocuteurs pour l'accompagnement
technique et administratif des
exploitants en effet comment accepter
quel que soit le montant réel des pertes
subies lors de catastrophe naturell en
mariniique tous les exploitants
reçoivent la même somme forfaitaire
aussi ma question estle monsieur le
Président comment votre syndicat entend
porter porter les besoins urgent de
simplification et d'accompagnement
attendu par les
agriculturs Cabanel merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président comme
l'a évoqué la présidente dans ses propos
liminires nous avons étit à l'origine
d'un rapport sur le malêtre des
agriculteurs en
2021 je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais tout ce que vous
revendiquez aujourd'hui et tout ce que
les agriculteurs revendiquent
aujourd'hui sur le revenu sur
l'agribaching sur la simplification
avait été bien spécifié mais je veux
juste revenir sur la première des
propositions qui est était donc de faire
de l'avenir de l'agriculture une cause
nationale euh aujourd'hui le Président
le premier ministre a dit qu'il fallait
placer l'agriculture audessus de tout
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas pris cette
proposition pour vous et de nous aider
aussi à à la mettre en place dès 2020
dès 2021 euh 2ème question ne
croyez-vous pas qu'il est temps que les
filières est une véritable stratégie à
la fois nationale et et et territoriale
et et je vais vous prendre un exemple
sur une filière que je connais bien la
viticulture je l'ai déjà dit ici mais je
vous le dis à vous
euh comment peut-on à la fois demander
donc des primes à la
plantation comment peut-on à la fois
demander des primes à l'arrachage
comment peut-on demander l'accès à l'eau
et et et croyez-moi je pense que dans un
département comme le mien et dans
d'autres aussi lesérau il faut de l'eau
mais pourquoi pour quoi faire parce que
en même temps demande donc des primes
pour la disilation donc je je pense
qu'il faut qu'à un moment donné ça soit
clair dans la stratégie et et et
troisème et dernière question qui était
éminidemment importante et notamment par
rapport au projet de loi d'orientation
agricole sur le foncier aujourd'hui 2
ti3 du foncier disponible va à
l'agrandissement des exploitations et
aujourd'hui quand on sait que 50 % des
installations se font hors cadre
familial on a besoin de foncier comment
pour pouvonsnous inverser donc la
tendance sachant que au niveau des sa
faire c'est quand même une mission de
service public et la première
d'entreelle c'est l'installation donc
des jeunes voilà monsieur le Président
je vous propose de répondre à ces trois
premières questions même si dans une
question il y en avait beaucoup
d'autres merci madame la Présidente je
vais commencer pas répondre à la
question du du sénateur Menonville bon
sur les les discussions qui sont
actuellement sur le sur la table bon il
y a des discussions qui sont
franco-françaises sur tout ce qui
concerne alors je vais prendre dans
l'ordre donc on pourra y revenir les
sujets donc ayant trait au au carburant
à l'énergie au GNR ça été annoncé il y a
des sujets et en trit au cout du travail
notamment à la reconnaissance de des
sujets autour de te que qui est un sujet
que vous vous connaissez bien les sujets
autour des des filières je pense
notamment à un grand plan autour de la
viande bovine qui est un un sujet de
préoccupation au moment où enfin je dis
VI bovin et d'ailleurs au moment où on a
une décapitalisation du cheptel
importante en France et et que je relie
avec la question des préie que j'ai
souligné tout à l'heure on a des sujets
évidemment de de VTI j'y reviendrai tous
les sujets de surtransposition autour
des des phytosanitaires donc on pourra
parler du conseil stratégique on pourra
parler des des sujets de séparation des
sujets de de d'instruments de mesure
enfin tout un tas de de sujets qui qui
questionnent les agriculteurs la
question de l'eau évidemment qui sera
aussi un sujet central j'ai discuté
récemment avec un certain nombre de
présidents de conseil départementaux je
pense notamment à la présidente du
conseil départemental de lariège qui me
disait qu'elle souhaitait pouvoir mettre
en œuvre un certain nombre de d'outils
de stockage d'eau avec de la maîtrise
d'ouvrage et qu'aujourd'hui la loi ne le
lui permet pas voilà donc c'est des
sujets typiquement sur lequel il faut
qu'on puisse revenir pour permettre que
encore une fois avec des modèles qui
peuvent être très différents parce que
celui de la riège n'est pas la même
chose que ce qu'on vit dans le
poidoucharant par exemple ENF en tous
les cas nouvellequitain n'est pas de la
même n'est pas du même tonneau et puis
ensuite des sujets européens dans les
sujets européens j'ai j'ai parlé de la
PAC mais il y a des sujets autour de la
directive industrielle qu'on appelle IED
dont une partie concerne
l'agriculture il y a d'autres sujets que
l'agriculture dans IOD mais enfin il y a
un volet agricole et et le trilogue qui
a abouti il y a quelques semaines
conduit à ce que si on ne change rien en
2028 un élevage de 21500 poules
pondeuses puisse être sur le même
parchier de compétition que son
homologue ukrainienne qui a un million
de voilill et qui rentre aujourd'hui en
franchise de droit de douane voilà je je
pose ça je prends forcément le cadre un
peu un peu élargi mais je je veux que
vous compreniez ça et puis après on a
les sujets évidemment d'accords
commerciaux alors je dis pas que tous
les accords commerciaux sont remett en
cause mais enfin il faut quand même
qu'on regarde les contenus celui qui
défrait la chronique en ce moment c'est
plutôt le le Mercosur don on sait que ce
qui gêne dedans c'est les 99000 tonnes
de viande bovine supplémentaire qui rent
je dis supplémentaire parce qu'il en
rendre déjà près de 300000 tonnes donc
voilà je et le sujet c'est pas
d'importer de la viande bovine là aussi
je voudrais qu'on soit précis je lis
beaucoup de de de contrevérité le sujet
c'est comment c'est produit voilà on a
du mal à comprendre qu'un élevage moyen
français de viande bovine qui est
d'environ 80 vaches alors plus la suite
hein les G c'est voilà euh soit comparé
à un fidelot sergentin ou brésilien je
vous invite à aller voir un jour si vous
êtes dans ces pays c'est entre 3000 et
5000 animaux c'est euh c'est voilà c'est
c'est c'est des sujets de décarbonation
importé pas systématiquement mais ça
mais ça peut-être voilà donc c'est ça
qui a qui a derrière par ailleurs on
peut aussi avoir des intérêts offensifs
sur le Mercosur je je ne le ni pas j'ai
essayé de le dire tout à l'heure voilà
donc et puis enfin dans les sujets du
moment il y a la question ukrainienne
alors là aussi je vis très parce que bon
l'Ukraine est en guerre l'Europe doit
apporter son concours à un peuple qui se
bat pour sa liberté ses frontièr son
modèle très bien bon donc il y a pas de
malentendu mais l'Ukraine est un grand
pays
agricole c'est à peu près un/4 de
l'Europe agricole dans le moment dans
lequel on est qu'on vienne en aide aux
Ukrainiens je pense que tout le monde
peut le comprendre mais ça n'empêche pas
de poser la question agricole je vous
donne quelques exemples il est rentré il
rentrait d'habitude avant le conflit
20000 tonnes de sucre ukrainien en
Europe il en est rentré l'année dernière
près de 700000 tonnes je pense que tout
le monde comprend qu'à un moment en
terme de déstabilisation des marchés il
y a un problème bon qu'est-ce qu'on dit
nous on dit que il faut qu'on trouve à
partir de de clause de sauvegarde la
possibilité de faire rentrer quelques
volumes parce que après en franchise de
droit de douane parce qu'après tout
c'est pas c'est pas choquant qu'on qu'on
continue commercer mais que le reste on
regarde comment éventuellement on peut
faire des corridors pouréexporter parce
qu'on comprend bien que les ports de la
mer Noire sont pas aussi disponibles
mais ce sujet il faut l'adresser et si
vous posez la question un agriculteur
polonais ou roumain il sera encore plus
déterminé que ce que je viens de de vous
dire donc le sujet c'est pas de tomber
dans les agriculteurs ne pensent qu'à
eux veulent pas se soucier de l'Ukraine
il y a une réalité de de marché voilà
donc il faut quand même qu'on la regarde
parce que ça se traduit derrière par des
fermeture de de de d'outils sur tout le
territoire national voilà quand vous
avez une sucrerie et que vous êtes face
à ce sujet de compétition c'est c'est un
problème et et on pourrait le le
multiplier donc voilà ce sujet c'est pas
pour dire encore une fois l'Europe est
une île on veut rien faire mais on a
besoin de de le regarder et puis ensuite
il y a tout ce qui est sujet
simplification parce que là on peut en
faire alors il y en
a plutôt une bonne nouvelle annoncée par
le Premier ministre de dire on se met
autour de la table tout le monde est
invité dans les préfectures et puis on
on liste et puis après on agglomère et
on regarde ce qui est rapidement
faisable moi j'ai envie de faire cet
exercice il a jamais été fait après
est-ce que il donnera du fruit ou pas je
je veux pas voilà notre rôle c'est de se
mettre au boulot du type de ce que je
viens de vous éclairer typiquement sur
le GNR l'annonce qui a été fait sur le
pied de facture nous paraît aller dans
le bon sens voilà parce que tout ce qui
permet à un agriculteur de passer un peu
plus de temps à son à son activité
principale et un peu moins à remplir des
papiers va dans le bon sens voilà donc
ça on a envie bon j'ai listé les mesures
de manière rapide he mais voilà et puis
après je le redis il y a tous les sujet
législatif donc installation
transmission compétitivité souveraineté
alimentaire je je je continue madame la
Présidente alors sur la question de du
sénateur du Val de la Martinique bon
d'abord on n'oublie pas l'agriculture
ultramarine je le dis aussi parce que
j'ai eu nos collègues de la Réunion il y
a quelques jours qui après le cyclone
était quand même dans des conditions
difficile alors vous parliez je vais
essayer d'être concret sur l'adaptation
du finance des chambres et des aides
voilà bah là on est typiquement dans le
cadre européen puis qu'en fait le
dispositif des minimis qui permet
d'apporter du soutien se fait dans un
contexte européen pour pas que ce soit
distorsif et le déminimis aujourd'hui
est plafonné pour l'agriculture je dis
bien pour l'agriculture à 200000 € donc
aujourd'hui si on ne peut pas aller
au-delà des 20000 € monsieur le sénateur
c'est parce que le cadre européen ne le
permet pas voilà donc après je dis pas
qu'il faut pas un plafond hein mais là
aussi on demande à ce que ce plafond
puisse être augmenté il l' été dans
d'autres secteurs d'activité donc c'est
c'est c'est c'est possible voilà mais
l'explication très concrète des raisons
pour lesquelles un moment on peut pas
aller au-delà de 20000 € alors qu'il y
aurait des besoins bien supérieurs c'est
celui-là bon sur les sujets de
production et de commercialisation avec
les importations y compris de produits
voilà bon le cœur du sujet pour nous
avant la commercialisation c'est la
production ce que nous disent les
producteurs martiniqu je vais prendre
l'exemple de la banane que vous
connaissez bien c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils
ont un certain nombre de contraintte de
production not ment parce qu'ils ont des
maladies parasitaires du bananier et que
sur la circosporiose noire notamment ils
ont des problèmes de de production donc
il faut qu'on arrive à regarder comment
on peut continuer à avoir un appareil
productif qui nourrit et puis ensuite
vous posiez la question du du déboucher
je je rappelle que dans le cadre de la
loi aujourd'hui on est censé dans les
cantines de Martinique mais mais comme
de de métropole d'avoir
50 % de production donc de qualité ou 20
% de bio ou signe de qualité et qu'on
sait aujourd'hui que les objectifs fixés
par le gouvernement à son propre à sa
propre administration ne sont pas
remplis voilà je je je je dis ça quand
même c'estàd que moi je veux bien
prendre un certain nombre de
responsabilités à regarder ce qu'on peut
faire mais il faut aussi que tout le
monde respecte le cadre d'engagement
donc le ministre deagriculture lui-même
a dit qu'il allait veiller à ce queon
puisse monter en charge je je sais aussi
et et peut-être les élus ici le savent
mais il y a aussi un sujet quand même
d'accès que quand vous augmentez le prix
de la cantine dans une école c'est c'est
vite un sujet de de de discussion or
voilà il faut qu'on accepte de discuter
de de de ces sujets moi je dirais que le
prix de la cantine pas trop mon mon
sujet mais comme il se trouve que je
suis élu local j'entends aussi ce que ce
que ce que les gens disent il faut
accepter que dans un certain nombre de
cas ça puisse valoir un peu plus cher
pas beaucoup plus cher un peu plus cher
et que on peut aussi avoir des produits
importés à bas cout mais qui ne
remplissent pas ses ses objectifs sur le
foncier bon c'est pas qu'un sujet
ultramarin si je puis dire parce il y
avait aussi la question posée par le sén
Cabanel mais sur le foncier je dans le
cadre des discussions avec l'État et ça
me fera peut-être une transition il y a
aujourd'hui un ce qu'on appelle un sdrea
un schéma directeur d'attribution des
terres disponibles avec le
l'installation en premier critère voilà
après on est dans un cadre alors parce
que vous parliez des safaires mais il y
a pas que les safaires il peut aussi se
faire des affaires de gré à gré la
Safire n'est pas n'est pas
systématiquement présente il faut
d'abord que comme dans tous les trans
action il faut que le vendeur et
l'acheteur se mettent d'accord
accessoirement et ensuite il y a des
critérisations donc c'est installation
ensuite c'est confortation et ensuite
c'est agrandissement c'est comme ça que
c'est prévu dans les schémas
départementaux après il s'applique ou il
s'applique pas il peut y avoir quelques
non mais
je voilà moi je constate comme vous que
parfois il peut y avoir des des des
sujets ça a été aussi renforcé dans le
casadre de la loi sans
pasous qui prévoyait qu'on puisse aussi
contrôler les transmissions de part
enfin les transmissions
partielles de part sociale bon le sujet
de fond c'est l'accès des TER c'est
aussi le modèle derrière ou les modèles
que que que ça développe et et nous ce à
quoi on tient c'est vraiment la
possibilité pour l'agriculteur quel que
soit encore une fois la production le
revenu et le territoire que il en viv
c'est c'est ça qui qui compte pour nous
donc on a aussi des endroits aujourd'hui
où où le foncier trouve difficilement
preneur voilà il y a aussi des sujets
dans certains une région très spécifique
de de des prises agricoles euh voilà
donc je je regarde ça aussi avec
beaucoup de de de de recul parce que
quand vous avez comme dans votre région
des endroits où il a plus moins de 100
mm ou 120 mm en une année sur la
question de la production ça pose quand
même des questions et que ce soit la
vigne même un olivier a besoin d'un peu
d'eau voilà donc je sais qu'on travaille
sur est-ce qu'on peut mettre de main des
amendiers de la vigne voilà mais il y a
aussi ce ce sujet là donc derrière le
foncier il y a aussi la capacité du
foncier à dégager du du revenu
euh sur sur la filière
viticole bon on est très conscient de ce
qui se passe hein c'estàd que à la fois
vous l'avez dit en 3 ans deux campagnes
de distillation qui ont atteint des des
des des des sommets et pas seulement de
de vin on va dire standard mais y
compris de vin en AOC je je pense à
Bordeaux qui la dernière fois a mis des
quantités très importantes a des tarifs
je crois que c'était 75 € lecto en AOC
on peut pas dire que ce soit
rémunérateur et pourtant des volumes ét
là très
importants en ce moment le sujet c'est
pas tellement les aides à la plantation
en ce moment le vrai sujet c'est les
aides à l'arrachage et avec un débat
iompris à l'intérieur de la profession
en n étant pas viticulteur je je prends
la distance nécessaire mais entre
arrachage temporaire et arrachage
définitif chacun expliquant qu'il faut
le plus d'arrachage possible mais plutôt
dans les appellations des autres enfin
je je le fais
euh
un peu rapide mais vous me pardonnerez
mais enfin il y a aussi un peu ça bon
aujourd'hui le sujet c'est quel marché
quelle segmentation et quelle re
commerciale parce qu'on a aussi beaucoup
de vin qui arrivent d'Espagne dans des
conditions d'importation et de la
franchisation qui parfois questionne bon
donc là ce travail il doit être fait
rapidement parce que la situation n
n'est pas tenable et d'ailleurs dans
dans les actions qui ont été faites
depuis quelques jours là où c'était le
plus compliqué où la colère était la
plus grande c'était souvent dans les
zones
viticoles avec une tradition viticole
que vous connaissez probablement mieux
que moi et qu'on a vu ressurgir je pense
à des acte qu'on ne peut pas accepter
voilà donc en tous les cas pour ce qui
est de la FNSEA et de son
volet et de son action autour des sujets
de viticulture on est on est très au
clair sur la nécessité de de de regarder
la segmentation des progrès avaient été
enregistrés il faut aussi donner acte de
ce qui a été fait depuis 20 ans
notamment dans le langdoc après la
viticulture elle est plurielle parce
qu'on parle beaucoup du Lang dog de
Bordeaux mais les sujets sont pas les
mêmes si vous êtes en Champagne ou en
Bourgogne donc il faut aussi regarder ça
avec voilà je le dis aussi on avait des
des secteur qui marchaent très fort je
pense notamment au cognac et qui
connaissent depuis quelques mois un un
frein important notamment parce que
l'exportation et notamment sur le
continent américain était très largement
voilà et comme toujours quand vous avez
des marchés qui sont qui poussent
beaucoup vous pouvez prendre quelques
mauvaises habitudes et quand le marché
se resserre de manière assez brusque
être en difficulté et je le dis aussi
parce que dans les primes à la
plantation euh le gros de la troupe
concernait cognac voilà près de 3000
hactares par an et donc je pense aussi
que là tout le monde va prendre
conscience qu'il faut être un peu
raisonnable pardon on est à la veille de
Oui Oui mais ou aussi depuis 10 ans on
implante énormément euh énormément de de
de vignes et évidemment le marché étant
ce qu'il est euh quand ça tire tout le
monde en veut et puis quand ça freine on
sait plus quoi faire des vignes donc il
faut qu'on trouve aussi les bons
réglages
voilà alors rapidement si c'est possible
remémy Cardon Patrick Chauvet et Daniel
salmand merci madame la Présidente si je
j'en crois les chiffres du ministère de
de l'agriculture vous le savez mieux que
moi 25 % des agriculteurs dépassent des
revenus agricoles de plus de 100000 par
an et 25 autres en dessous de 30000 par
an bref certains gagnent de mieux en
mieux leur vie quand d'autres ont de
plus en plus de mal à boucler les fins
de mois alors monsieur le président de
la FNSEA puisque vous prétendez défendre
et je vous pense sincère là-dessus
défendre le revenu des agriculteurs
coûte que coûte que pensez-vous de
plafonner les marges de la grande
distribution pourquoi vous ne le
revendiquez pas alors que nous savons
très bien c'est demandé et attendu par
la
profession merci Patrick
Chauvet Patrick Patrick Patrick pardon
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président merci de de votre Présence JE
SUIS sénateur de de Normandie
avec les mêmes questions qu'ailleurs je
crois et je reviendrai sur un volet
qu'il me semble un peu oublié dans dans
les revendications que je partage et et
et ce qu'on entend finalement c'est ça
c'est ça s'est construit sur sans doute
20 20 20 à 30 ans je voudrais savoir
quel est comment vous vous voyez les
choses par rapport au ministère de
l'Agriculture moi j'ai le sentiment que
on a des ministres compétents de très
bonne volonté et ça aurait pas de sens
que de taper sur les hommes ou les
femmes qui qui prennent ces
responsabilités là mais que le ministère
n'a plus de poids parfois l'impression
que le ministre se bat d'abord en
interne avec d'autres ministères se bat
avec les agences au pluriel avec la Cour
des comptes rappelez-vous qui dit qu'il
y a trop de vache mais qui oublie de
dire que si on on diminue les vaches
faudra les acheter les produits ailleurs
ou alors faudra intensifier la
production à l'unité de des vaches
laitières enfin on entend plein de
contradictions et du coup ça matche déjà
à l'intérieur de la tête du de de ce
pays donc on entend peu
euh aujourd'hui au travers toutes ces
revendications là comment on peut
repositionner un vrai ministère de
l'Agriculture qui puisse agir au lieu
d'essayer d'être tout le temps pris dans
les contradictions les contradictions
inter ternes moi je voudrais aussi
souligner les les dégâts qui ont été
faits en communication tout à l'heure
mon collègue a évoqué l'agribaching moi
j'avais été à l'époque me suis dit mais
qui a pu inventer cette chose
aujourd'hui on entend que les Français
soutiennent leur agriculture c'est assez
logique c'est l'agriculture qui qui qui
les nourrit mais rappelez-vous de
l'agribaching la traduction d'abord on a
le droit de parler français c'est c'est
tapé fort laagribaching on peut socio
professionnellement faire du bashing
surtout on l'a vu sur les forces de
l'ordre on l'a vu sur d'autres
catégories socioppressionnelles mais les
dégâts que ça a fait chez chez les
agriculteurs c'est c'est c'est terrible
le ressenti d'être comme ça le Bou
émissaire d'une société je je crois
qu'il faut faire attention et qu'on
prête pas assez attention surtout
aujourd'hui au moment où on en est au
côté humain aux femmes et aux hommes qui
travaillent en agriculture moi j'entends
beaucoup les éleveurs on perd des
éleveurs en Normandie vous imaginez
l'image sans nostalgie d'un temps révolu
de la Normandie on perd des éleveurs
laitiers tous les jours en Normandie
mais il y a un peu tout ça il y a
l'aspect des filières vous vous en
occupez très bien il y a l'aspect des
réglementations et ça sera la fin de mon
propos mais qu'on remette l'humain au
centre de nos décisions au centre de la
table sinon ça tiendra
pas tout ne tient où que ce soit que
s'il y a des hommes et des femmes qui
peuvent agir et et essayer qu'il puisse
agir en en sérénité vous avez évoqué sur
vous alliez vous mettre au travail sur
essayer de la simplification je pense
que la pire des choses serait de de
créer un ministère de la simplification
parce qu'on aurait tout le contraire de
de ce qu'on souhaiterait je suis pas sûr
et j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
préfets que ce soit là que ça se passe
euh je n'ai pas personnellement la
méthode mais je crois qu'il faut la
structurer différemment pour mettre en
évidence que là-dessus ce sera du bon
sens et tout le monde le reconnaîtra les
injonctions contradictoires parce que
personne ne s'y retrouve mais on peut
pas ma crainte c'est que demain ça
s'arrête et qu'on continue et qu'on
continue et qu'on remette des normes
qu'on remette des superpositions
normatives et je vous rejoins vous avez
raison on a besoin d'un cadre mais je
suis pas sûr que au moment où tout cela
est très révélé dans la revendication et
à juste ce titre qu'on qu'on est mis en
œuvre ou qu'on prenne les moyens de de
résoudre ce problèmelà en agriculture
Merci à VOUS Daniel
salmon merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président le monde agricole
est en colère effectivement mais le
monde agricole est loin d'être homogène
aujourd'hui on a des énormes disparités
vous savez aussi bien que moi que que 20
% des agriculteurs captent 80 % des
aides de de la PAC et donc ça veut dire
que les 80 % autres se partagent les 20
% et ce ne sont pas que des producteurs
que des agriculteurs improductifs
qu'est-ce que vous pensez votre syndicat
est-ce qu'il soutient toujours les aides
à l'hectare ou pensez-vous qu'il faut
vraiment moduler cela que pensez-vous
aussi le plafonnement à combien
mettez-vous le plafonnement des aides
aujourd'hui pour qu'on ait une vraie une
vraie redistribution au niveau des
agriculteurs
dans mon département devant il y a des
eu des manifestations devant une
laitterie devant du groupe
savancia aujourd'hui c'est ces groupes
là font pression pour diviser les
agriculteurs ne respectent pas les
accords cadre que peut-on faire pour que
et bien il y a pas cette volonté de de
diviser pour mieux régner et toujours
faire baisser le prix de des 1000 lit de
lait on sait pourquoi ça décapitalise
tout simplement parce que les agricul ça
décapitalise en beauin tout simplement
parce que les agriculteurs n'y
retrouvent plus leur compte bien entendu
euh le libre échange dernière chose qui
qui qui vote les accords de libre
échange et où en est votre syndicat sur
ces accords de libre échange je vois
bien que il y a des des positions un peu
à géométrie variable est-ce que on doit
pas avoir un capte un peu plus clair et
puis la résilience on tape beaucoup sur
les normes alors on parle d'agribashing
j'ai l'impression qu'en ce moment c'est
plutôt le décolo
bashing comment fait-on pour faire en
sorte que notre agriculture gagne en
résilience et soit propre à s'adapter au
réchauffement climatique merci voilà
monsieur le Président je vous laisse
répondre à ces questions merci je vais
commencer par répondre à la question du
sénateur Cardon sur le sur les marges de
la grande distribution bon
d'abord moi je au moment où où je vous
parle je je ne sais pas et donc j'ai
demandé à ce que le ministre de
l'Économie monsieur le maire puisse à
nouveau comme il l'avait fait il y a un
an et demi digentter une enquête de
l'IGF l'inspection générale des finances
pour qu'on puisse avoir des chiffres
clair parce que vous observez comme moi
que chacun explique que c'est pas lui
mais c'est l'autre et que il est
parfaitement en règle donc moi j'attends
d'avoir ces chiffres d'abord la première
chose c'est que j'espère qu'on va avoir
un transfert de marge vers vers
l'agriculture c'est c'est c'est ça que
je c'est ça mon boulot bon voilà donc
après je j'essaie d'être là aussi tout
le monde a besoin de de vivre pour faire
tourner les entreprises donc ce qu'on
avait observé lors de la je vais parler
des derniers chiffres de l'IGF en attend
prochain parisque le ministre a dit
qu'on devrait les avoir sous quelques
jours ou quelques semaines bon donc en
tous les cas la dernière fois on avait
constaté qu'il y avait un transfert et
c'est bien ainsi il était largement
temps puisqu'on avait eu 10 ans de
déflation
auparavant donc sur ce voilà par
ailleurs pour être précis l'encadrement
des marges je je je je voilà sur le plan
législatif je je pense que c'est un peu
compliqué il y en a d'autres qui
demandent l'administration des prix
voilà je pense que ça ça c'est c'est pas
raisonable transparence mais c'est pas
la même chose que l'encadrement si je
puis me permettre voilà et donc la
transparence nous la demandons nous et
et et en fait il y a qu'une manière de
la voir assez rapidement c'est à travers
l'IGF parce qu'on a aussi un
observatoire des prix et des marges mais
qui a toujours 18 à 24 mois de de retard
et évidemment ce qui nous intéresse
c'est c'est de pouvoir regarder au mon
ce qui nous intéresse aussi avec la
grande distribution et ça c'est des
demandes qu'on formule dans le moment
dans lequel on est c'est de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait pas de négociation
entre l'industrie agroalimentaire et la
grande distribution tant qu'il y a pas
eu un accord entre les représentants des
professionnels les organisations de
producteurs je vais le faire un peu
rapide et l' et le monde de l'industrie
agroalimentaire ça me paraît important
dans la construction du prix en marche
avant ça nous éviterait aussi ce qu'on a
en ce moment c'est-à-dire un certain
nombre de grandes entreprises qui nous
disent moi au regard de ce qui est la
difficulté de la négociation que j'ai
avec l'industrie avec la grande
distribution je ne suis pas en mesure de
vous donner plus que voilà et et c'est
notamment le le cas dans le le lait
enfin voilà sans sans sans cité de
d'entreprise enfin concernant les
grandes distributions on a une
inquiétude parce qu'un certain nombre
d'entre elles se sont adapté à la loi
les Français font ça très très bien et
sont aujourd'hui en train de négocier
dans le cadre
européen voilà et et et du coup ce qui
nous intéresse c'est qu'on puisse
regarder comment cet esprit peut u pour
ça on a besoin de l'évolution du cadre
européen donc il faut qu'on on regarde
ça et du cadre national donc ça ça fait
partie des des discussion qu'on a
l'esprit c'est pas que des produits
alimentaires puissent être négociés au
niveau européen pour arriver en France
et détourner le cadre de la loi c'est
bien qu'on soit dans l'esprit de la loi
je note depuis quelques jours une forme
de bénévolence de la grande distribution
je m'en
réjouis voilà je je trouve que il
faudrait qu'on s'évite ce ce ce type de
moment de colère et qu'on puisse avoir
un peu de de
maturité il y a pas de naïeté dans mon
propos hein voilà mais pour nous la
question du prix elle est centrale voilà
je dis aussi que toutes les filières ne
sont pas encadrées par égalim voilà donc
je je je le dis pour pour qui peuvent
être des choix des filières elles-mêmes
voilà mais en tous les cas quand on
parle
d'élevage qui est le sujet qui nous
préoccupe en ce moment la question du
prix elle est centrale voilà et donc ça
ça va être regardé de de très très près
sur la question alors quel rôle pour le
ministère de l'Agriculture bon écoutez
moi je vais essayer de rester à ma place
voilà je moi j'ai besoin d'un
interlocuteur nous avons besoin d'un
interlocuteur on a maintenant un
ministère de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire on trouva le
signe était intéressant enfin ce qui
m'intéresse plus moi c'est l'efficacité
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui le budget du
ministère est essentiellement consacré à
l'enseignement agricole et et et
l'enseignement agricole attire plus
qu'il n'attirait il y a quelques années
qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle euh
mais pour le reste le gros c'est
l'interface avec ce qui se passe à
Bruxelles dans les négociations de de
tous les toutes les directive et puis
dans dans ce que sont les grandes
politiques notamment la politique
agricole commune et puis après c'est
l'interface avec le ministère de
l'écologie le ministère de la Santé
enfin un certain nombre de ministèr dans
lequel on a voilà donc comme vous
j'observe que c'est pas complètement
apaaisé et comme vous j'observe que
parfois c'est long et et peu efficace
moi je fais pas de commenta sur le
ministre je je ne les choisis pas je
travaille avec et ensuite je relève ou
pas la possibilité d'obtenir des
résultats mais en tous les cas il nous
faut il nous faut un il nous faut un
ministère de tutelle ça me paraît
essentiel et dans le moment dans lequel
on est ça me paraît encore plus
évident sur le sur l'agribashing bon
écoutez d'abord ce que j'observe c'est
que il est moins important que ce qu'on
avait il y a 3 ou 4 ans que les juges
ont fait ce qu'il fallait pour que les
gens qui s'autorisent à envahir des
élevages comme ça dans des conditions
enfin comme si on rentrait chez vous bon
tout ça est en train de se tarer a
quelques amendes un peu un peu calibré
qui ont été enfin il y a des jugements
en tous les cas qui ont été rendus qui
ont dissuadé de de ce type d'action bon
c'est c'est pas complètement terminé he
l'état voilà mais enfin bon on on
évitera jamais quelques quelques
excessifs mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
ça laisser des trac et la
question du bien-être en agriculture
c'est une question centrale alors mon
travail maintenant avec Monsieur damzin
enfin Monsieur cel faisait référence à
ce qui avait été fait mais voilà c'est
un sujet qui doit se poursuivre et qui
et qui
fait sur lequel on a encore beaucoup de
beaucoup de travail et d'une manière
générale c'est ça rejoint le sujet de de
de la santé mentale qui est un sujet qui
dépasse le cadre agricole je je le dis
aussi he très largement et qui nous et
qui nous préoccupe sur les sujets alors
élevage réglementation bien oui mais là
aussi je voudrais être on voit comme
vous la déc hitalisation de l'élevage et
singulièrement de l'élevage laitier il
nous reste aujourd'hui moins de 50000
éleveurs laitiers en France
et attirer des jeunes aujourd'hui en
leur expliquant que même avec un robot
de traite c'est quand même une astreinte
importante avec l'évolution de la
société c'est pas naturel même quand
vous êtes fils d'éleveur et que vous
aimez ce métier et que vous avez bercé
dedans c'est pas complètement évident
parce que la vie sociale parce que la
volonté d'avoir aussi une vie comme tous
les frça de votre âge n'adhère pas le
consentement immédiat et et ça pose
aussi la question de la taille et moi je
je je pense qu'il faut pas du tout
éluder ce sujet demain des tailles
d'élevage plus importantes et j'ai pas
dit des tailles d'élevage voilà mais des
des tailles d'élevage plus importante ça
permet des associations ça permet du
salariat et ça permet de pouvoir
profiter d'un weekend de temps en temps
d'un peu de repos ou de quelques jours
de vacances ce ce sujet il est il est
important dans la question
de
l'élevage sur la réglementation j'en ai
largement parlé quand enfin un ministère
de la simplification écoutez moi je
laisse ça à quiis de droit moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
obtient comme résultat et qu'est-ce
qu'on est capable rapidement de faire
sauter je note que chaque gouvernement
qui cesse explique que dans sa période
d'évolution il a pris x texte x loi
voilà donc on pèse au kilo on travaille
au kilo aujourd'hui très bien moi
j'aimerais qu'à un moment on puisse dire
aussi que la qualité passe par la
modération vous voyez et que et qu'on
puisse faire en sorte que de temps en
temps on se dise qu'il y a peut-être des
choses un peu à à nettoyer un peu comme
chez vous quand vous faites le grand
ménage et vous ouvrez des placards et
vous découvrez des choses que vous
n'avez pas utilisé depuis des années
voilà donc on a besoin de cet exercice
euh voilà après chacun reste dans son
couloir de nage moi je sais pas si c'est
un ministère si c'est un haut
commissaire si c'est un secrétaire je je
je ne sais pas ce que je sais c'est
qu'on attend des résultats sur nos
fermes
concernant
la la question du du sénateur salmon
alors là aussi le 2080 sur les zpac
c'est en Europe ça n'est pas le cas en
France donc non mais faut faut qu'on
soit précis voilà donc je vous donne le
chiffre en France c'est 80 % des aides
pour 47 % des agriculteurs voilà donc je
compte sur vous maintenant
pour pour porter cette cette
information je redis comme je l'avais
dit au début
vous avez ai 100000 agriculteurs qui
font moins de 25000 € de production
brute standard c'est pas mes chiffres
c'est les chiffres de la nation ils sont
vérifiabl évidemment et donc vous voyez
bien que aussi ça en terme de volume
d'aide voilà ça peut pas être ça peut
pas être comparable vous posiez la
question de la
redistributione je vais venir je vais
venir la question de la redistribution
donc au moment où je vous parle la PAC
prévoit déjà un volet de redistribution
puisque que il y
a une surprime sur les premiers hectares
52 premiers hectares enfin bon c'était
un débat politique j'y reviens pas mais
en tous les cas il y a il y a une une
aide
supérieure pour les les les premiers
hectares ensuite sur les aides à
l'hectare aujourd'hui c'est le modèle
européen il y avait eu des questions sur
l'aide à à l'actif qui ont été soulevé
pourquoi pourquoi la France n'a pas
enfin tout pourquoi la FNSA je me
contenter de mon rôle pourquoi la n'a
pas assumé ça parce que quand vous
regardez les chiffres aujourd'hui si on
prend ce modèle ceux qu'ont des actifs
ce sont les Roumains ce sont les
Bulgares ce sont des pays qui
aujourd'hui capteraient une part
importante du soutien sur cette base
c'est un débat qu'on a déjà eu des
dizaines de fois y compris à Bruxelles
donc après on peut dire on bascule à
l'actif
voilà je je en tous les cas quand ça a
été fait la dernière fois ce sujet
conduisait à un transfert massif vers
les gens qui sont encore
très très structurés en main d'œuvre
moins automatisés moins voilà et donc
très clairement on avait un transfert
assez massif voilà après l'aide à
l'ctare vous savez le sujet c'est
toujours de faire bouger les lignes tout
le monde dit bah maintenant on a qu'à
rayer la Pâque et on va la réécrire
quand je vois la difficulté qu'on a eu à
Bruxelles mais vous aviez un député
européen à côté de vous donc il vous le
dira la difficulté à Bruxelles de de
trouver un compromis entre État membre
avec une fois encore un niveau de
subsidiarité qu'on avait jamais vu dans
les précédentes réformes de la PAC
évidemment ça nous questionne nous ça
nous questionne nous mais on l'a écrit
on l'a dit voilà et il y avait à
l'époque la promesse que les PSN donc
les projets stratégiques nationaux
serait comparé politiquement entre je
suis au regret de constater que ça n'a
pas été le cas mais c'était l'engagement
qui était pris voilà et ça c'est pas
voilà donc
aujourd'hui d'abord un certain nombre
d'État membres étaient très en retard la
réforme s'est fait très dans la enfin en
tous les cas à la fin dans la
précipitation tout le monde rendait on
essa d'aller nous on demandait qu'on
puisse avoir les règles parce qu'il y
avait aussi des règles d'application de
la PAC et d'ailleurs dont on découvre
quelques écueils aujourd'hui puisqueau
moment où je vous parle une de nos
demandes là c'est que les 5 à 7 % de
dossiers qui ne sont pas ou
partiellement réglés puissent l'être et
on découvre quelques écueils je vous en
donne un il était prévu que pour éviter
que des gens puissent bénéficier d'ê PAC
jusqu'à 80 ans 90 ans
voilà à partir de des régimes de
retraite voilà le fait qu'on puisse plus
toucher d' PAC et là qu'est-ce qu'on
constate on constate que quelques
dossiers de gens qui parce que par
exemple la conjointe a travaillé dans la
fonction publique hospitalière par
exemple les trois qure premières années
de sa vie elle a aujourd'hui 64 ou 65
ans son régime est purgé automatiquement
elle touche 120 € par mois ou 100 € par
mois ou 80 € de de de sa période de
travail de quelques années au début de
sa carrière et là poum il y a plus d'
PAC voilà et là là on dit bah non c'est
pas l'esprit du texte là on dit bah oui
mais on sait pas comment on va faire fa
qu'on le fasse à la main voilà bon je je
je vous dis ça aussi parce que derrière
et je fais référence à ce qui a été dit
c'est des hommes et des femmes voilà
c'est pas que des machines et de
l'argent et voilà donc il y a des gens
aujourd'hui qui sont dans dans la panade
donc la redistribution je vous ai parlé
sur sur les les les accords commerciaux
et le fait que il y ait quelques
entreprises vous avez cité saintventicia
moi je n'en cite pas parce que en fait
ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas le le
nemchem c'est l'efficacité du dispositif
voilà nous on a besoin encore une fois
et je le dis ici parce que souvent on
explique que l'industrie l'agroindustrie
c'est pas bien puis alors moi je sais de
quoi je parle voilà quand on a un litre
de lait quand vous avez une brique de
lait quand vous avez un kilo de farine
quand vous avez une bouteille d'huile
sur votre table elle est pas arrivée du
champ de l'agriculteur ou deou de la
stabulation elle est pas arrivée
directement sur votre table et donc on a
besoin de partenair industriel non mais
je je l c'est pas évident pour tout le
monde donc or les fruits et légumes et
le miel tout a à peu près besoin de
passer entre les mains d'une industrie
alors je sais que l'industrie c'est pas
très moderne en France aujourd'hui mais
enfin nous on en a besoin voilà bon donc
ce qui nous intéresse c'est non mais oui
mais vous voyez bien le sujet le sujet
c'est la marche vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur non mais vous
critique pas moi j'entends toute la
journée que parce que au titre de la
profession agricole je préside un groupe
industriel qui transforme nos graines de
cols et tournesol en huile je seraiis
leés ésent du grand capital je me
permets devant les représentants de la
nation que vous êtes de d'éclaircir le
point voilà et donc ce qui m'intéresse
moi ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est de
prouver que on a besoin de
transformation on a besoin que ce soit
fait en France parce que la
transformation elle peut se faire
ailleurs et revenir chez nous c'est
notamment le cas dans la pomme de terre
quand vous êtes à la frontière belge
vous produisez les prommes de terre la
valeur ajoutée est fait en Belgique et
vous rachetez les chips en France
peut-être qu'on peut être plus
intelligent que ça et se dire que on
fait ça je dis ça parce que le sujet
c'est pas T ou t entreprise c'est c'est
le mode de négociation et donc là je
redis ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
pour nous il faut d'abord qu'il y a une
négociation entre les producteurs et
l'industriel et qu'ensuite en marge en
marche avant on puisse avoir la ngo avec
la grande distribution ça pose aussi la
question du consentement au paiement de
l'alimentation du modèle français voilà
qui est aussi un sujet central vous ne
l'avez pas abordé je m'autorise à le
faire tout le monde nous demande
aujourd'hui de l'alimentation de qualité
de proximité et de la naturalité le
consentement au paiement je je le
constate voilà je pourrais parler de
l'agriculture biologique qui traverse
une crise majeur Majeur parce que
aujourd'hui le marché en tous les cas la
demande n'est pas là et qu'on se bat à
la FNSA pour sauver ce qu'on peut sauver
en ce moment des entreprises et que
quand on nous explique qu'il faudra
qu'on en ait quasiment le double dans 6
ans ça ne nous paraît pas raisonnable au
moment où on est dans le contexte dans
lequel on est voilà et que ce qui ce qu'
qu'on souhaite c'est sauver les
entreprises qui aujourd'hui se pose la
question de se déconvertir et et et et
c'est le cas et c'est le cas enfin enfin
vous avez posé une question sur le libre
échange les accords de libre échange je
croyais que j'avais répondu je vais
essayer de préciser mon mon propos nous
ne sommes pas hostiles au commerce aux
échanges nous ne sommes pas pour fermer
les frontières pour les raisons que je
vous ai dit on a parlé de viticulture
tout à l'heure nous ce qui nous inquiète
c'est les sujet qui concerne la
réciprocité ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui
c'est que de mettre des clauses de
sauvegarde qui sont juridiquement
costaud de mettre des normes de
réciprocité ce qu'on a appelé les close
miroir à Bruxelles qui sont quand même
un peu comp à mettre en uvre un peu
compliqué à mettre en œuvre et enfin les
contrôles qui sont quasi inexistants sur
l'importation des denrées alimentaires
moins de 3 % de ce qui rentre en denrée
alimentaire en Europe fait l'objet de
contrôle nous questionne voilà ce qu'on
dit après moi je suis pas à les douanes
je voilà et puis je suis pas compétent
pour en parler je dis juste que il y a
une vraie appréhension de ça maintenant
moi en tant consommateur demander de la
mozzarella italienne ou un bout de
Serano espagnol ou de boire un café le
matin ça me pose pas de problème et donc
expliquer qu'on va produire du café en
France demain est pas complètement
réaliste donc voilà j'essaie de j'essaie
pardon oui mais voilà vous avez on sait
faire plein de choses même du jambon on
sait le faire aussi voilà mais acceptons
qu'il puisse y avoir aussi d'autres
produits qui font une alimentation de
qualité
voilà merci monsieur le Président alors
Guilin camb Jean-Marc Boyer Antoinette
Gul Guil merci madame la Présidente je
vais essayer d'être rapide et le plus
court possible je me suis rendu comme
beaucoup d'entre nous sur les points de
blocage de de nos exploitants agricoles
j'ai des questions tant philosophiques
que que pratiques d'abord très pratique
au pratique j'ai entendu beaucoup de la
part des des exploitants trois choses
revenir ou ressortir les lourdeurs
administrative française les loi
l'application de la loi égalime et les
normes est-ce que sur ces ces points là
par exemple vous avez eu depuis que vous
échang vous êtes en échange continu avec
le gouvernement depuis la semaine passée
est-ce que vous avez eu des avancées
concrètes deuxème deè
question un peu un peu plus général la
pâack qui était une véritable réussite
européenne et qui était un marqueur de
la construction
européenne provoque en effet un certain
nombre de de questionnements est-ce que
vous pensez que la vision européenne de
l'agriculture est telle qu'elle est
portée également par la France serait
serait à revoir et enfin 3ème question
puisque il me semble avoir constater sur
les points de blocage des divergences de
vue on va dire ça comme ça entre les
exploitants agricoles comment est-ce que
vous la Fédération vous essayez de
porter l'unicité du mouvement et de la
parole agricole merci
Jean-Marc oui merci merci monsieur le
Président pour votre pour votre
présence sur le terrain effectivement on
rend compre des agriculteurs qui sont
excédés excédés par des règles
incohérentes irrité par des des excès de
Z de l'administration qui fait appliquer
des des consignes qui ne sont pas du
tout qui sont totalement incohérentes
par des des fonctionnaires Alés dans la
proposition de loi de mon collègue
Laurent Duplon répondre à la crise
agricole il est proposé la suppression
de l' FB est-ce que quel quelle est
votre position par rapport à cette cette
proposition qui me paraît très très
importante dans le cadre des des
motivations que peuvent avoir les
agriculteurs actuellement deuxème
question on parle beaucoup des règles de
surtransposition en France j'ai pas
souvenir moi d'avoir voté des règles de
surtransposition dans notre assemblée et
donc qui décide aujourd'hui d'après vous
de ces règles de surtransposition qui
sont appliquées effectivement et qui
posent de réels problèmes 3è question
j'ai été très choqué de voir des blindés
face au tracteur
on a connu les émetiers en cagoulet qui
cassai tout dans les rues de Paris et
ailleurs avec des tirs de mortiers sur
les forces sur les forces de l'ordre et
les agriculteurs sont des gens quand
même raisonnables or le symbole est
quand même fort et je trouve
complètement déplacé donc quel est votre
sentiment par rapport à cette à cette
opération
Antoinette oui madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président de la moi ma
questionter sur les icide en 2021
l'incerne donc l'Institut national de la
santé et de la recherche a rendu publ un
rapport qui un rapport sur l'effet des
pesticides démontrant qu'il y a un lien
entre l'exposition au pesticides et la
santé des agriculteurs et a survenu
notamment de trois types de cancer le
cancer de la prostate le miéo multiple
et le lymphome
nonkinien donc ma question est la
suivante la lutte contre les pesticides
chimiques devrait être un combat commun
que vous devriez porter au côté des
écologistes que nous sommes je voulais
savoir quel était votre positionnement
sur ce point précis car nous voyons que
les premières victimes des pesticides ce
sont les agriculteurs ensuite bien sûr
les citoyens je vous remercie voilà
c'est à vous monsieur le Président merci
madame la Présidente donc sur la
question du du sénateur com donc sur les
les lourdeurs les normes bon vous avez
raison hein c'est ce qui aujourd'hui a
été le le déclencheur bon au moment où
je vous parle je n'ai pas de certitude
qui ont été annoncé par le Premier
ministre et et ses services nous on a
dit ce qu'on souhaitait voilà sur un
certain nombre de de de de
surtransposition qu'elle soit d'origine
enfin qu'elle soit faite sur le plan
européen avec des règles européennes
qu'on qu'on qu'on surtranspose en France
hein notamment sur les pesticides mais
on en dira un mot je vais vous répondre
madame et et puis sur toutes les normes
bon je vous ai parlé de la laine de
mouton mais je je peux vous en voilà le
sujet en fait ce qui est difficile c'est
c'est c'est le changement de culture
c'està dire que moi je fais pas de
commentaire sur les fonctionnaires je
pense que les fonctionnaires ils font le
boulot qu'on leur demande de faire
est-ce qu'on est capable à un moment de
se dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on met
quelque chose on puisse un l'étalonner
et dire qu'est-ce que ça remplace voilà
si on dit bah il faut tel type de norme
qu'est-ce qu'on de quoi on a plus besoin
et comment on le fait on se pose jamais
la question et en fait ce qui est
difficile mais l'administration
elle-même parfois se retrouve avec des
grilles de lecture qui font que ce n'est
pas les mêmes en fonction des
départements donc c'est ça qui nous
questionne et nous on dit mais il y a un
moment il faut faire simple j'avais pris
mais je me rappelle monsieur le sénateur
on avait parlé des a ensemble la
question de la ha c'est c'est c'est
c'est question un peu voilà tout le
monde dit ça a du sens il faut en mettre
voilà bon
14 12 ou 14 parties texte règlements qui
vont dessus niveau européen quand on
parle directive habitat quand on parle
directive oiseau niveau français date on
touche pas une voilà bon et on comprend
pas pourquoi les agriculteurs veulent
pas planter donc moi j'ai essayé de
faire l'exégèse j'ai essayé d'expliquer
qu' un moment quand vous n'en avez pas
et que vous avez pas d'ennui vous avez
pas forcément envie de vous en créer
alors que pour autant sur le plan
agronomique ou de la biodiversité ça
peut avoir du sens puis après on peut
même parler de de l'intérêt économique
de lae comment avec une e de main on
peut produire de la biomasse on peut
faire des choses mais il faut il faut
que voilà mais il faut que tout ça se
cadre avec des filières aujourd'hui on
est incapable de parler de ça incapable
de parler de ça voilà donc nous on
essaie d'avancer le Premier ministre a
annoncé que il ferait un seul texte
alors moi je sais pas si c'est un seul
qui reprend les 14 ou si voilà donc on a
très envie de discuter du contenu au
moment où je vous parle je ne sais pas
de quoi je parle donc j'ai entendu
l'annonce mais bon donc tout ce qui sera
de nature à nous faciliter la vie il ira
dans le bon sens je redis pour éviter
les excès on n pas dit que il y avait
plus de norme qu'on a pas dit qu'il y
avait plus de règles et que c'était
n'importe quoi voilà je je bon sur euh
la PAC bon le sujet c'est pas la PAC le
sujet c'est c'est le paquet vert c'est
le Green Deal donc nous qu'est-ce qu'on
dit on dit ce paquet a été discuté en
2019 à un moment où ni le covid ni la
guerre en Ukraine n'était conscientisé
peut-être qu'il avait des visionnaires
parmi vous enfin globalement les gens
n'avaient pas conscience de ça ce qui
nous gêne c'est sa déclinaison agricole
qui a un volet clairement mais c'est pas
moi qui le dis c'est un certain nombre
d'études d'impact y compris de la
Commission qui fait peser un poids sur
la production alors on pourrait dire
après tout on l'assume sauf que on est
dans un moment où on fait rentrer
d'Ukraine des denrées en proportion
importantes et y compris on importe
aujourd'hui de l'ordre d'un tiers de
notre alimentation en France c'est même
le cas en bio je le dis un/3 du bio
aujourd'hui consommé et du bio importé
c'est pas une tarde impimportter
simplement on peut pas nous faire un
procès en productivisme et en et et en
espèce d'excès voilà quand quand par
ailleurs l'Europe et singulièrement la
France qui est un en tous les cas j'ai
encore la faiblesse de le penser un
grand pays agricole importe un tiers de
son alimentation donc le sujet c'est de
rediscuter de la vision que porte ce
texte je dis aussi parce que j'entends
des gens qui disent on va tout mettre à
la poubelle on va recommencer de à Z il
y a des sujets qui demeureront le sujet
du défi climatique c'est pas un sujet
qui va disparaître que ça s'appelle le
Green Deal ou ou autre chose c'est un
sujet que les agriculteurs observent au
quotidien les sujets autour de la
biodiversité c'est des sujets sur
lequels on a aussi envie de de regarder
mais je dis dans le moment dans lequel
on est il faut qu'on puisse dire voilà
et la Pâque ne sera que la déclinaison
de je doute pas d'ailleurs qu'elle sera
ouverte à moyenne ou courte moyenne
échéance parce que il faudra qu'on
rediscute de ça je le dis aussi dans un
moment où on a quand même un rôle jeis
quand même parler du rôle export parce
qu'on a beaucoup parler voilà on a des
sujets notamment sur le pourtour
méditerranéen d'aliment qui sont très
importants alors on peut dire aussi on
laisse les ruses et puis nous c'est plus
notre problème mais derrière ça derère
la question alimentaire il y a aussi
toute la question de la géopolitique et
de la manière dont l'Europe envisage son
rôle moi j'entends j'entends quand
même l'Europe dire sur le continent
africain on a une responsabilité il y a
de la coopération dans des proportions
très importantesah la question
alimentaire elle fait partie de
l'équation pas que c'est la seule on
peut pas écarter ça sur l'unicité du
mouvement agricole voilà alors là aussi
toute moi ça on me répète depuis 10
jours vous êtes en train de vous faire
déborder par la base voulais- je vous
dire d'abord un le monde agricole c'est
le monde qui est le plus syndqué de tous
les secteurs économiques voilà plus que
plus que les ouvriers plus que les
cadres plus que les agents de maîtrise
c'est nous c'est chez nous qui a le plus
environ 40
%. prenez ce chiffre avec un peu de
recul bon donc effectivement il y a 60 %
de gens qui sont pas syndiqués mais
quand vous quand il y a des
manifestations sur la réforme des retite
je suis pas sûr non plus que tout le
monde est sa carte voilà mon sujet c'est
pas de savoir qui est syndiqué ou pas
mon sujet c'est qu'est-ce qu'on porte
pour l'agriculture française bon on a
deux compétiteurs syndicaux bah c'est
plutôt bien comme ça les gens ils ont le
choix voilà bon don un qui aujourd'hui
clairement je parle de la Coordination
Rurale porte des revendications en tous
les cas je suis pas là pour faire leur
promotion hein ils se débrouilleront
avec le gouvernement je sais qu'ils vont
être reçus donc ils diront ce qu'ils ont
à dire mais mais mais voilà qui qui qui
qui ne sont pas enfin moi depuis 10
jours vous pouvez reprendre mes mes
propos publics j'appelle tout le monde
au calme à une forme voilà je je
m'honore au moment où je vous parle
qu'il ait pas de policier blessés qu'il
ait pas de gendarme blessés que les
choses soient tenues est-ce que ça
tiendra je ne sais pas et effectivement
peut-être qu'à un moment les choses
partiront mais voilà je constate aussi
que le gouvernement est bien content de
trouver un interlocuteur avec qui
discuter on n peut-être pas des gens
fréquentables mais finalement quand il y
a personne autour de la table c'est pas
c'est c'est c'est pas facile non plus on
est dans un pays où le dialogue social a
quand même une place nous on a toujours
assumé ça ça ça fait 78 ans qu'on existe
voilà qu'après le gouvernement discute
avec d'autres bah c'est son rôle moi
j'ai pas de commentaire à faire et donc
que que le monde agricole soit pas
monoliique ça on sait depuis longtemps à
la
FNSEA je suis seraliier le premier VI
président de la FNSEA est un viticulteur
le deuxième est un producteur de viande
bovine du Cantal on a toutes les
productions tous les territoires toutes
les typologies d'exploitation et je vous
prie de croire que peut-être comme dans
cette maison de temps en temps il y a
des discussion un peu animée ce qui fait
notre force c'est qu'à un moment on
essaie de faire des
synthèses voilà qu'est-ce que voulez je
vous dise si un moment les gens veulent
une forme de radicalité ils le feront
enfin encore une fois c'est une histoire
de conviction moi j'ai pas peur d'être
minoritaire ça me pose pas de problème
vous voyez ce que je veux dire nous on a
dit quoi on a dit que un on restait
européen c'est important de l'entendre
dans le moment dans lequel on est on dit
pas vous avez compris depuis le début de
mon propos que je dis pas que ce que
fait la Commission et ce qui a été
décidé nous va voilà et même on comprend
pas à certains moment mais c'est pas
pour autant qu'il faut pas continuer à
penser la question agricole et
alimentaire en européen parce que en
face de nous quand vous parlez du
continent américain quand vous parlez
des Chinois quand vous parlez des Russes
il faut quand même qu'on soit un tout
petit peu lucide sur ce qui se passe
ensuite qu'est-ce qu'on dit on dit que
la question du revenu et de la
production sont des questions qui sont
centrales et ça a été dit les revenus
peuvent être très différents dans
l'agriculture et même je vais même être
très clair avec vous heureusement qu'il
y a des agriculteurs qui gagnent bien
leur vie et je je leur dis tous les
jours c'est pas une tare parce que la
vision de l'agriculteur français qui
serait forcément quelqu'un qui serait
dans la souffrance c'est pas non plus
très attractif au moment où il va
falloir qu'on attire des générations
quel que soit on parle toujours du du
modèle agricole mais ça me fait sourire
parce que il suffit de connaître les
territoires et je crois que je suis avec
des gens qui les connaissent un peu pour
se rendre compte que l'agriculture
bretonne n'est pas la même que
l'agriculture du Massif Central qu'être
seralier dans le Bassin parisien c'est
pas la même chose que d'être seréralier
dans le l'oraguet et que d'être
transfrontalier pardon d'être
agriculteur frontalier c'est c'est pas
la même enfin voilà donc la la typicité
elle est très différente dans une même
production dans une même production
faire du lait de montagne ou faire du
lait en Bretagne c'est pas la même chose
voilà bon donc ça c'est aussi je crois
notre force c'est notre force donc moi
je cherche pas voilà nous ce qu'on veut
c'est porter un message clair et d'être
des interlocuteurs crédibles voilà après
les agriculteurs ils attendent pas du
président de la FNSA et de la FNSA qu'
leur disent qu'ils ont à faire tous les
jours le sujet c'est que si demain il y
a plus d'interlocuteur on repasse dans
un épisode gilet
jaune peut-être que c'est ce qui se
passera peut-être que dans 5 jours c'est
ce qui se passera voilà après le sujet
c'est qu'est-ce qui s'est passé 3 ans ou
2 ans après les gilets jaunes il faut
leur demander je reste dans mon domaine
de compétence qui est l'agriculture donc
voilà on détient pas la vérité on porte
des revendications elles sont claires
elles sont posées sur la table d'autres
en on d'autres d'autres défendent leurs
intérêts encore une fois ce qui compte
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on est capable de
faire et je n'ai nous n'avons jamais
prétendu à la FN SAA être omniscient et
omnipotent mais en même temps on a une
histoire en ce moment je pense que tout
le monde est bien content qu'on soit là
parce que au moins on sait avec qui
discuter et puis après s'il y en a
d'autres et ben le gouvernement fera ses
choix le Premier ministre me demande pas
l'autorisation quand il ve recevoir
quelqu'un donc voilà je je suis très
clair sur le sujet je veux pas qu'il y
ait de voilà ensuite la question du du
sénateur Boyer bon les règles
incohérentes les les voilà je pense que
j'ai un peu déjà voilà sur l'ofb vous me
dites est-ce que la FNSEA demande la
suppression deofb bon l'ofb c'est un
vrai irritant à la FNSEA parce qu'en
fait c'est la relation qui est pas
comprise bon personne ne pense que
demain enfin s'il y a plus l'ofb queil y
aura pas de sujet autour de la police de
l'eau ou ou la police de l'environnement
enfin c'est c'est pas sérieux de le
penser bon donc la question pour nous
c'est quelle relation
entre ces gens et et la profession
agricole alors il y a tout un tas de
sujets qui ont été mis sur la table les
sujets de la relation entre le
contrôleur et le contrôlé les sujets des
méthodes voilà bon première élément
qu'est-ce qu'on a demandé on a demandé
que que ce corps puisse être attaché au
préfet les préfets sont les
représentants de l'État voilà et que
donc le préfet puisse
avoir une discussion avec l' FB et que
ça soit pas seulement dans une relation
avec le procureur de la République ça
nous paraî important ça se passe comme
ça avec les forces de l'ordre ça se
passe comme ça avec les forces de
l'ordre voilà donc après tout ça ça nous
pas important et et je le dis on a
entendu une demande forte aussi du côté
des préfets voilà mais sans vous
interrompre je crois que ça a été fait
dans la loi 3DS aujourd'hui les préfets
sont les référents despartementau de
l'ofb vous avez raison c'est dans la loi
3DS mais en fait c'est pas appliqué
voilà c'est ça parce que les préfets ne
s' saisissent pas voyez c'est non non
non bon mais attendez bon moi je fais
pas de commentair de cette nature je je
dis juste que aujourd'hui effectivement
il y avait quelque chose dans la 3DS
mais ça n'est pas appliqué ça n'est pas
appliqué et donc dans la discussion
qu'on a aussi avec le Premier ministre
c'est on dit qu'est-ce qui fait que les
textes qui sont pris sont appliqués
parce que ça aussi ça interrogé
agriculteurs moi j'ai un sujet de
confiance en ce moment les gens me
disent tous de toute façon on se fait
avoir depuis des années ils nous disent
que et on se fera voir moi il y a un
moment il faut bien qu'on s'appuie sur
des éléments tangibles sinon sinon après
bah sinon après on est plus dans le
cadre on change de cadre bon donc ça
c'est
donc rattachement au préfet et le
Premier ministre a proposé qu'on se
mette autour de la table pour voir
comment on pourrait avoir des
discussions
autour parce que il y a deux métiers il
y a le métier administratif puis y a le
métier répressif en tous les cas voilà
donc c'est pas la même chose donc
comment comment on intervient dans ces
deux métiers comment on le fait avec
avec quel cadre mais en tous les cas ce
sujet il est très attendu par le monde
agricole sur les blindés face au
tracteur bon écoutez moi je je tout ça
est tout ça est un voilà nous on a dit
où on se mettait il y a rien qui a été
fait sans qu'on en ait parlé au préfet
avant on est en lien avec les autorités
pour que les choses soient encadrées un
moment les autorités souhaitent mettre
des blindés en face des tracteurs tout
ça enfin je vais vous dire chacun fait
son métier nous on fait le nôtre et je
vais vous dire si ça devait mal tourner
ce que je ne souhaite absolument pas
c'est pas de blinder voyez le sujet
n'est pas de cette nature donc tout le
monde tout le monde tout le monde fait
voilà l'État exerce son autorité dont
acte voilà je je voilà nous on essaie de
faire en sorte qu'il ait pas de
débordement et je le redis depuis le
début on essaie de tenir une ligne
plutôt de responsabilité voilà c'est pas
facile je ne sais pas si ça tiendra mais
en tous les cas pour ce qui nous
concerne on est très clair sur la
question madame la sénatrice sur les
pesticides alors bon ce sujet anime je
vais vous dire en tant qu'agriculteur ce
qui est mon sujet moi pour produire
aujourd'hui j'ai besoin dans un som de
cas de pesticides c'est une charge pour
moi si demain je peux m'en passer je
vous le dis je le ferai sans aucun
problème je vous ai dit qu'on était dans
une des agricultures les plus durables
au monde donc je regarde aussi ce qui se
fait
ailleurs je dis que si on peut trouver
demain des méthodes alternatives
l'agronomie qui est en train de revenir
très fort la question des sols la
question des couvertures si on peut
trouver des biostimulants de la
protection de toute nature on y est prêt
même d'autres produits il y a deux
sujets sous-jacents première c'est la
trajectoire la deuxè c'est
l'investissement pour trouver les
solutions parce que quand on dit par
exemple on retire une matière active
pour des raisons de toxicologie ce que
je peux comprendre par que vous l'avez
dit vous-même on est utilisateur
voilà non mais j'ai même pas parlé d'
pour le moment je dis quand il y a une
décision publique de retrait une
molécule moi je considère que si elle
est mauvaise en France elle est aussi
pour un Allemand et un Belge voilà c'est
pas ce que j'observe aujourd'hui
voyez-vous donc ça ça questionne c'estàd
que je vais prendre l'exemple des
néonicotinoïdes je je voilà
l'acétappride qui est un néonicotinoïde
aujourd'hui est utilisé en Allemagne en
traitement aérien je vous invite à le
vérifier
voilà bon donc qui qui qui est de notre
point de vue pire que en traitement de
semence de betterave par exemple peu
importe c'est une décision qui a été
prise donc aujourd'hui vous avez à
l'intérieur de l'Europe des
homologations de matière Activ qui sont
européennes toutes pas passe par l'EPSA
ça c'est voilà et après vous avez des
autorisations de mise en marché qui sont
nationales je redis que si à un moment
il y a une molécule qui pose problème
elle pose pas problème à un français et
pas un Allemand ou pas un Belge voilà
premier élément ensuite je dis que sur
la recherche et l'innovation il faut
mettre des moyens rapidement je l'ai dit
le PDG linraay le
sait moi j'ai besoin de tous les acteurs
je le redis aussi public privé hors
Europe faut mettre les meilleurs autour
de la table pour qu'on trouve les
solutions parce que en revanche
qu'onacceptera pas c'est notamment ce
qui se passait en seriz c'est dire il y
a une molécule on la retire vous avez
une petit un petit insecte là qui
s'appelle la drosophile qui vient piquer
les serises qui les rend impropre à la
consommation al pas de manière
systématique je rentre pas dans les
détails mais voilà et qui conduit à des
pertes de produit cette année très
importante et à de alors 100 % dans
certains endroits pas partout voilà et
qui conduit à de l'importation et est-ce
que est-ce que le consommateur français
ou parisien qui va trouver des serises
Turques bien brillantes bien poli sur
son étal qui ont elle-même cette matière
active sort grandit de cette discussion
je ne le crois pas voilà bon donc le
sujet de qu'on a synthétisé de manière
très rapide dans pas d'interdiction sans
solution c'est quelque chose qui est
important pour nous c'est quelque chose
qui est important pour nous moi je je
suis pas le représentant de telle ou
telle firme je dis que j'ai besoin de de
solution technique la betterave est un
cas moi sur ma FME en 2020 j'ai eu de la
jaunice j'ai fait 20 % du rendement que
je fais d'habitude j'ai besoin de
solution il y a un pnri qui a été fait
avec des investissements pour essayer de
trouver des méthodes alternatives y
compris par la génétique je le dis parce
qu'à Bruxelles on a des discussion en ce
moment sur les NBT les nouvelles
technique de sélection et on voit bien
que ça fait débat entre ce bien sûr
entreux qui concne qui considère que je
le fais à peine de manière caricaturelle
que ce sont les nouveaux OGM et ceux qui
disent que quand même la mutagénèse a du
sens pour accélérer la recherche et
permettre que demain on est aussi sans
breuvet le vivant c'est l'agriculteur
qui vous le dit on est des solutions
pour avoir des plantes qui
soient plus résistantes à des attaques
d'insectes à des attaques de champignons
peut-être même au problématiques
climatique ça a du sens pour nous voilà
parce que moi j'ai besoin de solution et
si la solution c'est on produit plus et
on importe ben je ne l'accepte pas voilà
je j'essaie de vous le dire comme ça et
encore une fois euh je voudrais aussi
qu'on donne acte des progrès qui ont été
enregistrés depuis 20 ans parce que ce
qui est difficile aussi et ça ça fait
partie des discussions c'est qu'en fait
à chaque fois on dit fait des efforts
mais jamais on dit bon il y a eu des
progrès fait quand on regarde ce qu' les
progrès qui ont été fait sur les cmr1
sur les cmr2 il faut un moment pour
qu'on continue et qu'on ait une
dynamique qu'on donne acte des progrès
enregistrés voilà je je le dis euh et il
y a pas une solution miracle ce sera une
combinaison de solution et ça c'est
important mais c'est pour ça que je
redis que ce qui est important c'est de
continuer à produire et ceux qui disent
c'est zéro phyo faut
rien sont pas sont pas raisonnables
voilà je vous dis comme je le pense Anne
crine Loisier Amel gaker et Yannick Jade
ou merci président aller très vite
beaucoup de choses ont été dit donc avec
les deux niveaux de de questionnement et
d'attente au niveau intérieur et au
niveau plus européen au niveau intérieur
vous avez évoqué donc la l'application
des des lois égalim j'attire juste en
complément votre attention sur le fait
que dans la la restauration hors
domicile il y avait aussi des
engagements de l'État pas seulement dans
les qutines scolaires mais dans les
l'administration de l'État dans les
présons les hôpitaux et autres et et
même des engagements qui allaient
jusqu'à 100 % de VI bovin pris à
l'époque par Julien Normandie donc voilà
je pense que sur ces volets là il y a il
y a un levier vraiment sur lequel il
faut insister ma question à ce stade du
débat sera juste sur le le vol européen
la la singularité c'est qu'on a quand
même là une mobilisation je pense comme
jamais c'est-à-dire que ces 18 derniers
mois c'est pratiquement 16 ou 17 pays
enfin les agriculteurs de de nombreux
pays européens qui se sont mobilisés
donc il y a il y a une vraie remise en
cause on va le dire de la de la de la
stratégie agricole
européenne donc est-ce que vous sentez
que là il y a un levier particulier pour
remettre nous ce que nous demandons nous
l'avons demandé à plusieurs reprises de
remettre farm tout fa sur la table de
remettre aussi aujourd'hui la la la
stratégie de gestion de de de l'Ukraine
enfin de notre soutien à l'Ukraine parce
que si demain on répond sur les
problèmes intérieur mais que cette
situation là elle demeure je pense que
on reverra nos agriculteurs dans dans
quelques mois dans le même difficulté
Amel merci madame la Présidente beaucoup
de choses ont été dites je vais je vais
juste aborder la problématique des
filières exclusivement régional qui
rencontre de graves difficultés
difficultés qui mettent en danger la
totalité de production en fait française
et et c'est à court terme je vais parler
de ce que je connais évidemment le mieux
dans ma région 95 % des endives voilà
sont produits dans les haut de France
mais il n'y a pas que la betterraave le
CH de Bruxelles et et clairement des
fières aujourd'hui en danger qui doivent
également bénéficier en fait de plan
d'urgence au même titre que celui qui a
été évoqué pour la viticulture il s'agit
surtout pas d'opposer les cultures ce
que je dis juste c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
faut des réponses pour tous une question
allez-vous aller jusque là dans vos
conditions d'arrêt du mouvement que nous
soutenons bien sûr je vous remercie
Yannick jade merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président vous conviendrez
quand même que si le Green Deal et tout
ce qui est autour du Green Deal peut
susciter des inquiétudes ça ne peut en
aucun cas être mis comme responsable de
la crise actuelle puisqu'on parle au
fond de choses qui potentiellement vont
se mettre en œuvre on est d'accord que
cette crise aujourd'hui elle est longue
elle est structurelle elle est
extrêmement dure et c'est pour ça que
que nous la soutenons mais il faut qu'on
fasse attention aussi les uns et les
autres dans les arguments qu'on met
qu'on met en avant euh un point de
clarification sur au fond le débat sur
l'exception agricole qui a été prononcé
par le premier ministre et notamment
dans nos relations au commerce
international bon il y a pas besoin
d'accord de libre échange pour vendre du
vin ça se boit à peu près partout dans
le monde et c'est et c'est tant mieux et
c'est notre et c'est notre fierté
on voit les clauses miroir on les défend
moi j'ai toujours combattu les accords
de libre échange on les défend on voit
en c'est le mercosour qu'est-ce que vous
dites sur l'agneau néozélandais parce
qu'il y a pas de d'enjeu de close
miroire l'élevage extensif néozélandais
au
fond même rendu en Europe il est plus
écolo que dans les dans les évaluations
que l'agneau français et moi je défends
que on protège l'agneau français contre
l'agneau néozélandais qui a pas à faire
20000 km pour un carré d'agneau donc au
fond comment vous situez par rapport à
ce type d'accord où au fond l'enjeu
c'est pas la clause miroir c'est le
principe du commerce international sur
des produits alimentaires liés à nos
filières et puis un point si vous le
voulez bien on a beaucoup parlé de la
décapitalisation dans le secteur bovin
et laitier notamment est-ce que vous
regrettez en tant que FNSEA finalement
d'avoir participé à la supession pr des
cotas laitiers qui était quand même un
instrument de
régulation du lait de stabilisation des
revenus des éleveurs et finalement
d'avoir joué le marché international ça
a plus déstabiliser les éleveurs et
renforcer
l'actalis monsieur le Président alors
sur la question de madame la sénatrice
Loisier et de la mobilisation
européenne bon moi je pense que ça ne
changera pas les choses avant l'élection
au mois de de juin voilà je pense que
tout le monde est en train de constater
l'échec c'estàdire que voilà je vous dis
on est en fin de mandature la présidente
F desayen elle-même qui avait assez peu
parlé d'agriculture dans les premières
années de son mandat commence à
comprendre que peut-être qu' y a un
sujet de cette nature je je je vois que
l'ensemble des parties prenantes ne se
satisfont pas de cette situation pour
des parfois des points de vue très
opposés voilà mais les les différents
groupes parlementaires qui composent le
Parlement européen voit bien la
situation dans laquelle on est et cette
situation vous l'avez dit inédite moi je
je jeai pas souvenir qu'on est autant
depuis 1992 et les grands débats sur
l'avenir de la PAC je n'ai pas souvenir
d'une telle mobilisation européenne donc
tout le monde voit bien quel est le
problème les causes peuvent être parfois
très locales mais il y a quelques
raisons qui peuent qui qui qui sont
clairement européennes donc je ne vois
pas de de de réouverture possible en
revanche je je suis assez persuadé que
ça va occuper l'espace du positionnement
politique des différents partis qui font
des
propositions je je voilà ça permettra au
moins que la question agricole euh don
que tout le monde prend un bras le corp
depuis quelques jours retrouve voilà et
et c'est important puisque finalement
c'est c'est le premier budget européen
donc on parle de 27 à 28 % du budget
européen c'est quand même pas si neutre
que ça et et puis si ça peut permettre
une forme d'intérêt sur cette élection
ça ne sera que que mieux euh donc je je
vois pas ça en tous les cas pour la
réouverture
euh avant le avant le l'échéance
électorale sur l'Ukraine bon là pour le
coup on peut pas attendre le mois de
juin euh voilà donc nous on a demandé
très clairement que des choses puissent
être faites à Bruxelles je comprends que
ça frémit là avec la présence des des
chefs d'État et de gouvernement quels
seront les niveaux des annonces je ne le
sais pas euh mais évidemment les Claus
deonverte sont sont nécessaires mais là
encore je je trouve que le niveau de
réaction est quand même affligeant enfin
ça fait des mois qu'on explique qu' il y
a un problème voilà sur l'Ukraine et
puis tout d'un coup quand les choses
s'embrasent en quelques jours on va
trouver des solutions moi ça me
questionne vraiment sur la compréhension
la compréhension des des des grands
enjeux je je voilà je vous le dis donc
l'Ukraine on espère que là dans la
semaine on aura des annonces sur la
possibilité de mettre en place des
clauses de sauvegarde après est-ce que
c'est mettront en place tout de suite
dans quelques semaines voilà on a je
l'ai dit on veut absolument que ça
concerne les volat a les œufs le sucre
et les céréales et dans les céréales il
y a évidemment le maïs et le et le blé
et ensuite on veut veiller à ce que
l'année de référence soit 2022 et non
pas 2023 puisque l'année dernière comme
je vous l'ai indiqué voilà donc voyez il
y a des petits points de détail qui n'en
sont pas vraiment sur
euh sur votre question madame la
sénatrice vous parliez des
productions de votre région oui sur
l'endive on connaît le sujet le sujet
c'est qu'il un déserbon qui s'appelle le
bonalan qui est appelé à être retiré du
marché et qui n'a pas qui n'offre pas de
de solution dans un moment où cette
production pour pouvoir se développer a
aussi besoin d'énergie parce que en fait
le forçage des endives se fait AC de
l'énergie et donc on a espèce de
conjonction du facteur de j'ai pas les
moyens de protéger ma production et
l'énergie a explosé comme chez la
facture de tous les Français et du coup
je je me retrouve en grande difficulté
de production y compris avec la
possibilité de voir disparaître cette
production en France que tout le monde
se rassure on continuera à manger des
endives en France voilà mais ell ne
seront plus de produit chez nous c'est
un problème voilà et donc on revient à
la question que je disais tout à l'heure
sur qu'est-ce qu'on met en place pour
trouver des réponses techniques qui
permettent de continuer à produire sans
qu'on ait sans qu'on ait finalement
l'arrêt de la production parce que les
gens disent voilà mais je pourrais
prendre ça avec la carotte de créant je
pourrais prendre ça avec tout un tas de
d'éléments donc là on est vraiment on
est vraiment dans le
[Musique]
dans dans le sujet et vous m'avez posé
la question des conditions d'arrêt alors
je suis très à l'aise parce que en fait
d'abord on va écouter ce qu'à nous dire
le Premier ministre voilà ensuite on
interrogera nous nos troupes pour savoir
est-ce que ça paraît entendable pas
entendable
voilà je l'ai dit il faut bien qu'on
explique qu'il y a différents timings
bon d'abord il y a des mesures d'urgence
attendues je l'ai dit
mais je je l'entends depuis hier il y a
des gens qui disent par exemple nos
collègues bretons nous disent moi j'ai
un problème avec le ratio prairie
pardonnez-moi c'est un peu technique
mais enfin c'est l'idée que y compris
quand vous avez arrêté l'élevage depuis
6 mois on vous dit vous devez
réimplanter des prairies et on nous dit
ça on sort pas tant qu'on l'a pas mais
en même temps moi je suis obligé de leur
dire que ça c'est une décision
européenne et que la France seule ne
peut pas emmener cette décision et que
au m titre que les 4 % de jacher qui
questionne l'obligation jaer questionne
et que on y est depuis 9 mois on prend
que peut-être de manière dérogatoire il
y aura des choses dans le qui qui
pourrai sortir mais voilà donc il y a
des choses françaises qu'on peut avoir
tout de suite sur la directive IOD au
niveau européen qui est aussi très
attendu en viande blanche je pense au
poupondeux je pense à la dinde je pense
au port voilà c'est une décision qu'on
pousse beaucoup mais il y a eu un
trilogue à Bruxelles donc on est en
train de regarder si on peut
éventuellement il y a des possibilités
de de de de rouvrir avec des amendements
si le le vote n'a pas lieu tout de suite
alors en plus je le dis IED prévoit que
avant l'entrée en application de la
directive en 2028 il y a une clause de
revoyure en 2026 moi j'en découvre tous
les jours mais voilà
donc ces conditions elles seront
définies puis ensuite il y aura le
troisème temps je vous l'ai dit he
mesure d'urgence mesures européennes
puis les mesures législatives et là je
me tourne vers vous qu' un moment ça va
vous passer entre les do
voilà donc je parle pas des des PPL qui
peuvent être déposés par les différents
groupes parlementaires je parle de ce
que va porter le gouvernement est
proposé aux deux assemblées dans lequel
on va voir si l'agriculture est
auudessus de tout alors je je redis ce
que j'ai dit on a pas demandé ça on veut
juste que un moment on prenne la place
qui est la nôtre voilà et que les les
les mots les mots se traduisent dans les
faits qu'est-ce qu'on dit sur
agriculture d'intérêt général majeur
voyez il y a un moment parce qu'en ce
moment tout le monde nous dit qu'il nous
aime je suis ravi hein mais on va quand
même un moment passer au travaux
pratiques voilà euh est-ce que quand on
dit il nous faut des intues d'impact
dans la loi ça a du sens est-ce qu'à un
moment on peut dire on a aussi besoin de
veiller à ce que il y ait le droit de
l'environnement et il en a besoin mais
il y a aussi un sujet de souveraineté
alimentaire et et que on ne vienne pas
les entrechoquer en permanence est-ce
qu'on peut trouver un équilibre voilà ce
qu'on demande nous et donc on verra bien
ce que sont les conditions j'ai rappelé
les différentes ématique sur l'eau par
exemple il faudra qu'on lève un certain
nombre de de freins parce que le
stockage de l'eau c'est c'est c'est
nécessaire et qui aura pas d'agriculture
sans eau voilà donc après il faut faire
attention au milieu enfin aller
expliquer que par exemple dans le Pas de
calis chez vous madame il y a en 2 mois
près de
180 millions de mè cubes d'eau qui ont
été rejeté à la mer par des pompes et
que par ailleurs pour irriguer toute la
région pas juste le département toute la
région il en faudrait moitié moins c'est
quand même une question de bon sens
alors je dis pas qu'il faut le faire
n'importe comment je dis pas qu'il faut
le faire partout je dis pas qu'il faut
le faire de manière déraisonnable je dis
juste que se poser la question relève du
bon sens
voilà ben écoutez je je peux vous
dire mais j'ai je vous ai parlé de la
région monsieur jade voilà vous êtes de
l'INE oui bon donc vous c'estes pas un
Paul d'len non pas encore bon donc
stocker de l'eau dans dans dans cette
région dans cette région des Haut-
de-fance c'est un sujet y compris parce
qu'on on y produit beaucoup de cultures
spécialisées beaucoup de cultures
spécialisées et que donc on aura besoin
d'eau et que même cette région des Haut-
de-fance peut demain avoir des sujets de
sécheresse majeur donc voilà il faut
qu'on le regarde voilà quant au ple
d'air puisque vous y faisiez référence
monsieur le sénateur nous par exemple on
s'interroge pourquoi quand c'est un pole
d'air en Hollande et ils ont un tout
petit peu d'expérience sur les sujets de
Pole d'air il y a une obligation légale
de curer les faussées et si vous ne le
faites pas vous êtes amendable et en
France si vous le faites vous êtes
amendable peut-être qu' un moment
peut-être qu'à un moment on peut avoir
un peu d'intelligence collective sur ce
sujet voilà donc les conditions de de
sortie sont à à regarder sur les
questions de de monsieur le sénateur
jado
euh bon vous dites il y a un paquet mais
il y a pas de loi enfin vous connaissez
un peu le sujet et moi aussi on a un
tout petit peu parlé de de NRL on a tout
petit peu parlé de chour ces différentes
directives européennes discutées pendant
des mois donc je veux dire aujourd'hui
chour on sait ce qu'il en est devenu
mais NRL est toujours là on sait pas
comment ça va sortir encore voilà donc
ça explique pas la la
d'jourd'uiacord non je dis que quand
même ce que ça contient à questionner le
monde agricole voilà je vous ai expliqué
que c'est la criseaujourd'hui c'était de
la sédimentation je je le redis donc je
n'explique pas que c'est un facteur
conjoncturel qui explique aujourd'hui je
dis que structurellement l'accumation
crée l'incompréhension et que ce que je
vois remonter aujourd'hui parfois des
gens qui me demandent de revenir sur des
choses qui ont 15 ans voilà donc je je
dis pas du tout que c'est ça je dis que
simplement pour essayer de redonner
parce que moi ce qui m'intéresse dans le
moment dans lequel on est c'est de
redonner une vision c'est qu'on soit
capable de se projeter à 6 mois à 5 ans
à 10 ans c'est ça qui attend le monde
agricole là là on est planté là on est
planté bon mais il y a un moment le rôle
qui est le nôtre c'est essayer de de
redonner une vision c'est de dire
l'agriculture a encore un sens en Europe
l'agriculture elle peut encore faire
vivre dignement des gens elle a du sens
dans le métier elle nourrit les gens je
je je note avec intérêt que que que les
gens sont plutôt sensible à ce qui se
passe en ce moment et plutôt
positivement sensible je suis pas sûr
que ça dure longtemps s'ils soit ils
sont embêtés tous les soirs rentrant
chez eux mais en tous les cas on entend
ça donc ça fait partie du package
d'ailleurs depuis le début j'explique
qu'il y a des sujets français donc c'est
pas ça c'est pas l'Europe Europe moi je
fais pas partie de ceux qui revoient à
Bruxelles systématiquement parce que
c'est facile de de viser Bruxelles je
dis que il y a une part de
responsabilité à Bruxelles IED c'est un
irritant qui est sur la table parce que
encore une fois l'éleveur breton il
comprend pas il comprend pas voilà donc
il comprend pas que on lui explique que
il a un élevage industriel qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que on
l'empêche pas de produire mais ça veut
dire qu'on va lui demander de remplir
plus de
papi c'est c'est
en port par exemple c'est c'est c'est
120 truit alors que la moyenne nationale
française est autour de 170 180 mais 120
truit aujourd'hui si vous remplissez des
papiers toute la journée les gens disent
mais c'est cfcayen voilà c'est ça que je
veux dire et après moi je vous parle du
ressenti parce que les gens n'ont pas
conscience de de ce qui se passe donc je
ne dis pas que c'est que ça mais je dis
que ça peut participer vous me posez la
question de l'exception agricole mais
comme vous je la découvre depuis hier
donc je je je m'intéresse beaucoup parce
que je connaissais l'exception
culturelle donc du coup C on a commencé
à travailler pour regarder s'il pouvait
y avoir des parallèles mais au moment où
je vous parle je ne sais pas voilà mais
je je manquerait pas d'interroger le
Premier ministre mais puisque j'ai
compris qu'il venait cet après-midi
faire sa déclaration de politique
générale dans cette maison je vous
remercie si vous lui posez la question
de l'éclairage de ce que c'est que
l'exception
agricole très bien bon ben
écoutez en tous les cas voilà mais moi
je je en tous les cas qu'on regarde
l'agriculture avec intérêt me va bien
vous savez les agriculteurs les mots les
formules les trucs machin c'est
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire endure vous
voyez qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire dans la vraie vie des gens je
crois que c'est ça qui nous intéresse
euh un petit mot sur l'agnau
néozélandais ouis
bon et vous avez dit tout l'intérêt
d'abord je voudrais donner le chiffre on
importe aujourd'hui 60 % de notre viande
auovine 60
% la consommation
donc ça veut dire un que nous on peut
progresser on pe en produire plus mais
je me réchouis monsieur jado que du coup
vous m'édier sur le loup ça va m'aider
beaucoup parce
que bah dans les Alpes dans les dans les
alpes5 départements venez dans les nous
aid non non non non si si non attendez
attendez si si si non mais non non pas
du tout pas du tout pas du je vais vous
répondre je dis je dis non que la
filière ovine aujourd'hui est
traumatisée par la question du loup mais
posez-leur la question si vous en avez
produit posez-leur la
question ne venez pas me voir
et non non mais
attendez je jou au bille je jou au bille
je je je
redis demandez au producteurs au vin
vous les connaissez bien allez les voir
demander quelle est leur préoccupation
par rapport à la prédation je dis le
loup mais je pourrais parler d'autrees
choses parlons structurel aujourd'hui
nous on sait bien qu'on va pas passer de
60 % d'importation à autoproduction donc
déjà ce qu'on voudrait c'est qu'on nous
aide la place de pouvoir en produire
plus avec des conductions de production
je vous ai parlé de la laine mais de
tous les véritant donc premier élément
il faut qu'on nous aide à produire voilà
et ce qui avait été fait dans la pack
avec des aides auovin et tout ça allit
dans le bon sens parce que c'était pas
juste des aides couplées à la production
c'était aussi des aides à la
structuration de la filière et c'est une
des filières qui sait le mieux
structurer je le dis parce que du coup
parfois les politiques publiques quand
même amène à des gains de productivité
sur l'importation donc première réponse
il faut qu'on en fasse plus vous avez
compris et donc tout ce qui est de
nature à voilà mais dire qu'on sera
autosuffisant demain donc il faudra
qu'on continue à importer ce qu'on nous
a dit c'est que c'était des accords des
accords de libre échange nouvelle
formule enfin voilà je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire close miroir nouvelle
formule mais non mais
voilà et on nous dit que quand on fait
l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie de
l'importation on est avec des choses
plus verdueuses moi ça m'interroge
beaucoup et puis je voudrais aussi qu'on
parle du sujet de bien-être animal parce
que il y a aussi des sujets majeur de de
de cette nature bon ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est comment on garde des
gens qui veulent continuer à faire de la
production au vin c'est ça qui
m'intéresse en France donc je je ne suis
pas en train de vous dire que de toute
façon faudra pas qu'on en importe on en
aura besoin ce qu'on comprend pas c'est
le cumul parce que là Nouvelle-Zélande
mais vous auriez aussi parler de
l'Australie dans lequel il y a une
louche supplémentaire qui est pas signée
à ce stade mais qu'on attend c'est le
signal qui est important monsieur le
sénateur le signal c'est de dire on
compte sur la production et puis après
si on en a pas et qu' faut en importer
euh acceptons de regarder ce qui nous
gêne en ce moment c'est que ça détruit
de la valeur et de la capacité de
production et donc quand je parlais des
iritants et que volontairement je je
disais que la prédation je je vous prie
d'entendre que le sujet de la prédation
c'est un sujet qui préoccupe les
éleveurs au vin il y en a pas partout
dans toute la France et les endroit où
ça se passe bien donc on a de la place
pour le marché il s'en consomme et on
peut aller plus loin donc faisons cet
effort euh ensemble et et veillons à ce
que on n'est pas euh de sujet vous me
parliez décapitalisation euh du cheptel
beauovvin c'est une vraie préoccupation
c'est une vraie préoccupation d'abord ça
fait partie de ceux qui ont aujourd'hui
les revenus les plus faibles en moyenne
voilà avec des sujets de alors je
distingue le lait de la viande bovine
c'est c'est pas exactement les mêmes
problématiques euh en lait je vous en ai
parlé en lait y compris parfois dans des
élevages de taille conséquente je pense
à la Bretagne il y a des gens qui
arrêtent de guerlass qui disent moi j'en
ai assez parfois voilà est-ce que les
quotas seraient de nature à à remettre
laanique je pense qu'on est au-delà de
ça vous savez les cotas quand ils ont
été mis dans le lait en 1984 personne
n'en voulait et puis quand on les a
retiré en 2014 tout le monde voulait les
garder non non mais ok tout le monde
nétait pas contre les non non non à
l'époque en globalement les gens en 84
étaient quand même pas super favorable
au cota voilà
voilà oui oui ce que je vous expliquer
c'est c'est l'état
d'esprit je pas parler de 84 mais voilà
quand en 2014 on a retiré les quotas
tout le monde a
craint libéralisme le marché
voilà je crois pas qu'on reviendra au
cota pour vous dire et dans le moment
dans lequel on est c'est même plus le
sujet dans le moment dans lequel on est
c'est l'attractivité du métier c'est
qu'est-ce qui fait que quelqu'un se dit
dans le moment auquel je suis je vais
accepter vous reprenez une exploitation
laitière il faut engager des capitaux
vous avez le cheptel le hangar un peu de
matériel quelques terres autour voilà
vous immobiliser du capital de manière
importante avec une rentabilité qui est
faible vous travaillez sensiblement plus
que la durée légale du travail il y en a
d'autres quand vous êtes commerçant
artisan vous saz travailler aussi donc
je veille toujours à pas donner le
sentiment qu'il y a que les agriculteurs
qui travaillent il y a beaucoup d'autres
gens qui travaillent mais enfin faisons
le constat que nous on travaille et et
enfin vous avez des revenus qui
sont alors il peut y avoir des bonnes
années en lait et il y en a eu et tant
mieux et elles sont méritées mais enfin
voilà et donc la fatigue elle est morale
aussi en l'IT voyez des gens qui disent
voilà je je donc comme les prix de la
viande étaient assez élevés l'année
dernière on a eu des la grosse
décapitalisation après il y a encore des
gens qui y croient et moi c'est c'est
c'est pour cela que qu' qu'on est là
c'est comment on fait pour continuer à
garder une production laitière vous
savez les grands acteurs si demain il
faut qu'ils aillent acheter du lait
ailleurs ils le feront mais on a aussi
des laitteries ancrées dans les
territoires qui fonctionnent et qui sont
d'ailleurs souvent celles qui payent le
lait le plus le le le le plus élevé et
puis on a aussi vous l'avez dit des
signes de qualité quand on est dans la
filière comptée aujourd'hui avec voilà
on oui mais ça veut dire je fais chcho
parce que là on est sur un marché où il
y a une autorégulation c'estàdire que
c'est pas des quotas mais mais mais à
l'intérieur à l'intérieur de
l'organisation on s'est mis des règles
j'aurais pu prendre l'exemple du
champagne aussi qui se met des règles
d'une année sur l'autre pour pouvoir
stocker des jus et et voilà donc je
trouve que quand même sans rentrer dans
l'encadrement du marché parce que ça je
pense que c'est plus d'actualité l'idée
en tous les cas qu'on puisse réguler
parce que il y a pas en agriculture de
solution en dehors d'une forme de
régulation c'est important je dis aussi
parce que tout le monde dit la FNSEA le
libéralisme et tout c'est pas vrai il
faut regarder la réalité de ce qu'on
produit donc en agriculture le
libéralisme c'est mortifèire mais
l'encadrement de tout et des prix c'est
pas crédit non plus donc il faut trouver
les vois et moyens et ce qui a été fait
dans un sememble de filièr le compter en
est une il y en a d'autres c'est
intéressant et et les filières locales
je pense par exemple à certaines
laitteries qui travaill des produits
spécifiques y compris l'UL acheté voilà
avec des prix il y a des gens qui payent
le lait très bien en ce moment avec des
écarts de prix qui peuvent être
supérieurs à 50 € les 1000 lit d'une
laitterie à l'autre ça ça interroge le
producteur laitier voilà donc nous on a
besoin encore une fois d' croire vous
saz l'élevage là il regarde ce qui se
passe il regarde ce qui se passe où on
est capable de donner une dynamique où
on est pas capable et moi je voudrais
finir par là si vous m autorisez madame
la Présidente encore une question ben il
non Jean-Claude Sébastien Anne Anne ou
allez on y va vite alors c'est sûr alors
Anne rapidement jean-clae oui merci déjà
monsieur le Président bon bien que c'est
narnais je pense quand même être
suffisamment objectif pour vous
réaffirmer notre soutien ici au Sénat
moi je voulais juste qu'on se penche 2
minutes sur les les perspectives de
diversification auxquelles on recourt
certaines entreprises agricole enfin
certains exploitants pour joindre les
debouts tout simplement votre regard
là-dessous la dessus pardon savoir si il
y a bon ben des des des diversifications
qui qui qui qui sont majeures
éventuellement des verrou que l'on
pourrait faire
sauter et voilà que qu'on ait votre
bilan tout simplement merci Jean-Claude
oui ben rapidement question si remarche
mais sur faisons attention à la
démagogie quand on parle de surposition
surtout quand on parle de de produits
phyau la France est quand même un des
pays qui autorise le plus de molécules
si on si on se compare à la Pologne à
l'Allemagne euh je nai plus en tête mais
et non mais je je je vous Sébastien
Sébastien sur la viticulture peut-être
encore une fois oh non plus politique un
peu de viticulture mais non moi je
passais la fin de la semaine là sur les
les manifestations avec mes confrères
viignon
et je suis inquiet je suis inquiet parce
que les les dérapages et
instrumentalisation politique faite par
notamment l'extrême droite qui a
tendance un peu à tiser à tiser les
flammes n on a trois députés qui se sont
pris en photo vers une pancarte qui qui
faisait référence à une affaire qui
concerne Sandrine Rousseau là va faire
la soupe donc vous voyez un petit
peu le niveau le niveau de de de ces
mecsl et je crois qu'il faut pas se se
voiler la face face à ces à ces
provocations gr grotesqu euh mais il
faut pas s'étonner que surviennent
ensuite des des dérapages assez graves
dans vos manifestations puisque nous
avons eu un attentat il y a 15 jours de
l'adrealal a explosé le matin à
Carcassonne et puis lors de la
manifestation de vendredi dernier c'est
c'est la la MSA qui a été carrément
détruite par le mouvement
viticole et agricole qui était justement
monté par par votre organisation
professionnelle et qui absolument pas
cautionné évidemment par les leaders
syndicaux donc moi je je je suis
particulièrement inquiet par rapport à
ça et je voulais avoir votre avis parce
que j'ai j'ai l'impression que ce jour
au-delà de tout ce que l'on a dit le la
problématique fondamentale que que
connaî le le secteur agricole
aujourd'hui il y a des pistes réflexion
mais derrière ça je pense que se joue un
rattrapage politique par rapport aux
européenne bientôt et surtout aux
élections consulaires en fin d'année
j'ai j'ai j'ai vraiment l'impression que
que que l'extrême droite et la
Coordination Rurale joue ce match dans
ce temps politique
aujourd'hui je pense que la la
difficulté du monde agricole telle
qu'elle est telle que nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui et cette
désespérance mérite mieux que des
calculs politiques en vue de de ces
élections là donc je je voulais vraiment
avir votre avis sur ces encombrant
soutien infiltré dans vos manifestations
organisées par la FNSEA et puis enfin
bon ce matin il eu des annonces au
niveau viticol moi je suis assez
satisfait de du résultat puisque nous
nous demandions des fond fond d'urgence
million d'euros il sera 80 millions
d'euros dé primimes à l'arrachage est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est ce sera
suffisant pour régler la crise viticole
qui touche inégralité des régions
françaises aujourd'hui merci voilà
monsieur le Président pour clôturer
votre longue et au combien intéressante
intervention alors pour répondre à à la
sénatrice charch donc sur
diversification verou euh d'abord il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'exploitations
agricooles beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui
ont déjà fait de la diversification
parce que tout le monde cherche des
solutions et c'est pas nouveau donc il y
a des gens qui vont faire de
l'agrotourisme il y a des gens qui vont
faire de la transformation à la ferme il
y a des gens qui vont faire tout un tas
de de de de produits voilà il y a y a il
y a quelque chose qui monte assez fort
c'est la production d'énergie hein de
plus en plus de gens qui mettent des
photovoltaïques sur les bâtiments
d'élevage qui s'intéresse au sujet de la
méthanisation qui se renseigne sur les
sujets de demain de d'agrivoltaïsme
voilà avec tous les les tensions que ça
peut exercer sur la pression du foncier
sur sur tout un tas d'autres sujets mais
en tous les cas la question de la
production d'énergie interroge beaucoup
et puis voilà les les la diversification
c'est pas nouveau est une solution et et
va continuer à l'être et puis je vous ai
parlé des services pour enfin des
paiements pour services environnementaux
ça aussi c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
continuer à à pousser parce que on pense
que c'est une source de de revenu euh
sur les surtranspositions monsieur le
sénateur je vous en donne une comme ça
vous verrez que ah donc voilà moi en
fait ça ça m'intéresse pas tellement de
de de chercher je dis il y a des
surtranspositions j'ai parlé des
néoniques par exemple tout à l'heure qui
qui qui qui est flagrante bah écoutez
quand c'est autorisé dans un pays et pas
autorisé en France AC l'UR France pas
demandé la bonne dérogation vous savez
c'est pas unepition c'est que la France
a demandé les semen en
alors non mais non non mais c'est bon je
je non non mais je partage pas votre
point de vue monsieur le sénateur mais
c'est pas très grave voilà enfin à
l'arrivée ce que constate l'agriculteur
français c'est qu'il l'a pas etvec son
voisin là et que l'Europe le permet
voilà bon oui oui bon mais encore une
fois moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas de
chercher voilà c'est de dire parce que
je vois bien ce qui est en train de
monter comme débat on voudrait opposer
la production et l'environnement ça ne
nous intéresse pas ça nous intéresse pas
je dis pas que c'est votre propos mais
c'est quand même ce qu'il voent en ce
moment donc je je je précise puisque je
suis puisque je suis devant des
parlementaires
voilà en gros en expliquant que il y a
ceux qui jouent la production l'argent
le grand capital et puis de l'autre côté
ceux qui protègent l'environnement moi
je dis simplement si demain il y a plus
d'agriculture française ou moins
d'agriculture française c'est plus
d'importation est-ce qu'on aura gagné la
réponse c'est non comment on fait demain
sur les leviers de décarbonation
d'amélioration si on n pas la prod vous
savez pour qu'un
sol capacité de décarbonation faut qu'il
produise et qui stock voilà donc ça il
faut qu'on en parle ensuite moi je je je
je me bats pour qu'on essaie de de pas
opposer la question de la haie étant un
sujet voilà donc tout ce qui est de
nature à faciliter la ligne entre les
décisions parce qu'il faut des décisions
il faut un cadre réglementaire je dis
pas que il faut rien et ce qui se passe
dans nos fermes nous va bien et donc il
y a des sujets sur transposition
environnementaux il y a pas que ça il y
en a d'autres il y a pas que
l'environnement non plus il peut y avoir
aussi des sujets sur transposition dans
d'autres domaines donc il faut qu'on les
regarde il faut qu'on bien sûr c'est
pour ça que je je je focalise pas sur
l'environnement vous voyez je je je dis
il faut qu'on les regarde qu'on les
prenne et puis qu'ensuite euh on dise
euh voilà et puis peut-être qu' ai
parfois la surtransposition nous a aidé
vous voyez j'essaie de rester euh voilà
j'ai pas beaucoup d'exemples mais
peut-être que ça peut exister donc moi
mon sujet c'est qu'on reprenne et qu'on
regarde si ça facilite ou pas et qu'on
aille au bout et ça c'est très attendu
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien sur enfin la
question de de des
inquiétudesez moi je encore encore une
fois je je je
porte je porte ce qui est la ligne
politique de notre syndicat je sais pas
ce que faut le Front national je je fais
pas de commentaire politique moi je je
me contente de de rester dans mon dans
mon domaine qui
est le syndicat professionnel agricole
que je représente avec des
compétiteurs les autres font ce qu'ils
veulent vous voyez ce que je veux dire
et les gens se définiront moi je l'ai
dit publiquement un le temps des
élections au champ deagriculture vient
c'est dans un an je suis pas sûr d'abord
je suis persuadé que la plupart des
agriculteurs qui sont aujourd'hui sur
les barrage
l'ignore donc ça n'est pas la question
du moment voilà que certains les en tête
j'ai pas de doute mais les agriculteurs
là ce qu'ils veulent c'est des réponses
concrètes maintenant tout de suite dont
ils ont le sentiment que ça va changer
leur vie demain dans leur ferme c'est ça
qu'ils attendent donc vous parliez de de
l'enveloppe viticole elle est supérieure
à ce qui avait été demandé donc première
chose pe dire il y a un signe qui est
donné vous l'avez dit aussi il y a
beaucoup de choses qu' ont déjà été
faites pour la viticulture le sujet de
la viticulture c'est un sujet très
conjoncturel avec un malêtre que que
tout le monde a ressenti c'est d'essayer
d'apporter des solutions de court terme
la vrai le vrai sujet de la viéticulture
mais ces gens-là le savent très bien
pour les avoir rencontrés à plusieurs
reprise c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait du
marché comment on adresse la question du
climat est-ce qu'on essaie de trouver
une solution pour la question de l'eau
quand elle est possible comment on fait
de la segmentation parce que il y a des
régions qui ont fait beaucoup de progrès
mais qui va arriver des vins d'entrées
de gamme qu'on francise dans des
conditions qui sont illégales voilà bon
donc c'est c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de discuter donc à court terme
c'est comment on sort les gens de l'eau
parce que il y en a qui sont en train de
se noyer et c'est essentiel de le faire
ensuite à moyen terme c'est tous les
sujets autour de l'arrachage temporaire
définitif je suis pas compétent c'est
pas à moi qui appartient d'en décider
mais en tous les cas qu'on aille loin et
puis ensuite qu'on discute de la vision
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de la vireculture
française qui est aussi une viticulture
très différente voilà parce que les
problématiques des uns sont pas les
problématiques des autres les choix de
segments qui ont été fait par les uns et
les autres ne sont pas les mêmes et puis
comment on essaie d'harmoniser ça dans
un contexte mondialisé où régulièrement
les vin et spiritueux français font
l'objet de de de contraintte quand
Airbus et Boeing se frotent c'est la
viticulture française qui trinque quand
Bruno Lemer dit a 15 jours les véhicules
électriques chinois on va pas financer
c'est un panel sur le sur le cognac
voyez donc tout ça concours à des
interrogations peut-être pour finir si
vous m'autorisez madame le Président je
voudrais dire ce que ce qu'on ce qu'on
veut porter d'abord à court terme euh
faire que on a un signe très clair que
le monde agricole est écouté ensuite je
le dis parce qu'on sait qu'il y a des
mesures d'urgence qui vont arriver mais
que d'autres prendront un peu plus de
temps on peut pas jouer avec ce
mouvement on ne peut pas jouer avec ce
mouvement
et il est pas question et il est pas
question que dans quelques semaines on
se rende compte que la fièvre tombant le
problème serait réglé il n'en sera rien
et donc on a besoin absolument que les
réponses en profondeur soient
apporté les réponses en profondeur soi
apporté alors nous on va
travailler pour essayer de trouver les
conditions qui satisfairont les gens qui
sont aujourd'hui sur le terrain et qui
les aident à comprendre mais ça c'est
pas de la responsabilité de la fnsoa
c'est de la responsabilité du
gouvernement et donc faut bien que
chacun porte ses responsabilités donc la
fnsoa elle elle dit ça va ou ça va pas
mais elle commande pas voilà elle décide
pas à la place du gouvernement bon
ensuite il y aura une fin je sais pas
quand elle sera mais il y aura une fin
il y aura le temps du travail sur les
sujets de simplification parce que ça ça
peut pas être juste des mots donc il
faut que ça se traduise dans les cours
de ferme qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
simplifier demain il y a eu des annonces
de faête les annonces elles vont dans le
bon sens mais les annonces les
agriculteurs ça fait longtemps que ils
disent bon maintenant ça fait fait
quoi faudra probablement une dizaine ou
une quinzaine de jours on a le salon de
l'agriculture qui commence dans 3
semaines qui est un moment de communion
avec les Français qui un moment de de de
bienveillance d'accueil d'explication il
faut que ça le reste enfin il faut que
tout le monde soit conscient aussi que
si d'ici 3 semaines il y a pas il y a
pas ce qu'on attend ça va pas être la
visite de santé on vient faire les
photos au cul des vaches je je je
préfère le dire aussi très clairement et
donc voyez bien que la position de la
FNSEA c'est en responsabilité de se
battre pour trouver des solutions parce
qu'on peut dire aussi ça va pas ça va
pas faut tout péter très bien mais il y
a un moment c'est quoi après voilà donc
nous on met les propositions sur la
table elles satisfont elles satisfont
pas en tout les cas nous on fait notre
travail de proposition d'un syndicat on
travaille main dans la main avec les
jeunes agriculteurs parce que on
considère aussi que c'est important que
les plus jeunes et aussi leur mots à
dire la manière dont on construit
l'avenir puisque je vous ai parlé
d'avenir
voilà on dit aussi que l'agriculture
c'est c'est c'est aussi un métier qui
garde du sens qui garde de la noblesse
qui a des sujets aujourd'hui de revenus
de prix on a parlé des galimes on a
parlé de la structuration on a parlé des
importations mais il faut absolument que
ce qui s'est passé là serve à
reconstruire une forme de une forme
d'élan et je l'ai dit en France mais à
Bruxelles et donc la question de la
campagne de la place de l'agriculture
dans la campagne d'ici le mois de juin
central et je j'ai la faiblesse de
penser pas seulement en France mais dans
de nombreux États européens et que pour
ce qui nous concerne en tous les cas sur
la question du Green Deal on va
s'employer parce que il faut donner une
ligne claire il faudra probablement
rouvrir la PAC parce que quand on parle
de du ratio prairie quand on parle des 4
% de non production qui sont encore
dérogatoire au moment où on parle voilà
il faudra quand même qu'on dise les
choses et je le dis parce que j'ai
entendu ou lu qu'on dit ils veulent pas
aujourd'hui il y a déjà 2,1 % de jcher
en France donc il y a pas rien il a pas
rien c'est faux de le penser voilà mais
mais on dit juste les régions sont pas
les mêmes et il faut qu'on adapte parce
que territorialiser c'est aussi mieux
faire comprendre les politiques et on
peut pas dire de Bruxelles jusque dans
mon territoire il y a pas de typicité
donc il faut qu'on fasse attention et je
dis ça parce que ça veut pas dire qu'on
peut pas avoir une vision commune mais
qu'il faut aussi l'adapter à ce que
c'est ce qui'est la réalité des des
territoires on est dans un moment
difficile je le dis aussi euh devant les
gens qui sont ici assumer la
responsabilité avec les élus qui
m'entourent de ce syndicat professionnel
c'est aussi prendre ses responsabilité
voilà c'est ce qu'on a fait je pense
qu'on l'a fait avec avec vraiment le le
recul nos gens nous entendent toute la
journée dire ce que sont nos élus nos
nos no no nos adhérents mais même des
nonadhérents tous les agriculteurs nous
entendent avoir des propos clairs après
il y a des gens qui portent autre chose
et bien très bien moi je vous vous aurez
noté que à aucun moment je n'ai fait des
commentaires voilà donc je n'oppose pas
les agriculteurs entre eux je ne l'ai
jamais fait je comprends que la FNSA en
ce moment espèce de défouloir c'est pas
grave la ligne est connue que nos
concurrents portent leur vision moi je
je je vous le dis je connais des
agriculteurs qui sont dans d'autres
syndicats je n'oppose pas les
agriculteurs entre eux j'ai du respect
pour tous les pour tous les agriculteurs
mais nous on a dit clairement ce
qu'onortait maintenant c'est au
gouvernement qu'il appartient d'apporter
les réponses et puis on commencera après
je voulais vous remercier de votre
accueil ben c'est nous qui vous
remercions vraiment très sincèrement
parce que vous nous avez consacré plus
de 2hures d'échange et de débat dans le
moment que vous avez rappelé au combien
compliqué qui vous mobilise euh je
dirais jour et nuit donc merci merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci
d'avoir répondu d'une façon aussi claire
transparente et et précise vous savez
qu'ici au Sénat voilà quels que soient
les bancs sur lesquels les uns et les
autres siègent l'agriculture nous nous
rassemble pour une grande grand partie
en tout cas nous mobilise pour qu'on
puisse faire avancer les choses et soyez
assurés que on prendra toute notre part
lorsque le débat législatif en
souhaitant que ça n'arrive pas trop trop
dans trop trop de temps même si le
premier ministre a dit qu'il fallait
encore concerter et on prendra toute
notre part et on échangera de nouveau
très volontiers avec vous et on vous
souhaite beaucoup de courage pour les
heures et les jours à venir merci
beaucoup
merci